with reports from Monday um and that is
important because um uh any early bills
need to get reported out today um and we
have one early bill on the schedule for
today that I think we can take care of
uh pretty easily um so we'll do that
early this morning so we can get the
report done and out on that um but I
think um talking to representative
Cornell
um we wanted to uh caucus um both sides
for a few minutes um so we will uh go
into caucus briefly before we start um
voting on the
you
e
back um
and uh we're going to see if we can put
the exec session on speed
dial um and the first um first bill we
763 and uh I call on representative uh
dry I think you have a motion yeah we
start with a motion for oop pass thank
you uh is there a second I'll second
that thank you and repr the dve to have
a further uh discussion on that and an
amendment possible I would like to make
a motion to adopt amendment number
H is there a
second representative
Morris um representative TR would you
like to speak to your Amendment this is
a very simple Amendment it just kind of
tightens things up um one we discussed
uh whether we should include charter
schools in this because they needed to
be mentioned specifically if we wanted
to include Public Schools but uh on the
advice of of chairem my chairman um the
charter schools don't have athletic
fields this is about aeds and athletic
fields if this we find that this is a
problem down the road it's easy to amend
but at this point it seemed um
extraneous what we really wanted to to
talk about is the bill itself said that
the AED should be readily accessible at
each athletic event or venue and talked
about places where they might be maybe
four soccer fields together did we need
does that mean four um aeds or is one
enough um for that and what we did is
look back in the guidelines guidelines
from the American Heart Association for
example say um when you're doing an AED
plan plan for having something within a
three to five minute walk try to do the
best you can to get as much coverage as
you can and it really so we don't need
to put that in statute what we need to
do is say we're going to ref ref we're
going to refer to the guidelines and we
changed um it from at each venue is they
will be readily accessible to each venue
so the AED is in the area it's easy to
go from one field to the other but we're
not mandating that we have a AED on
every field physically and I think we
can try to that would that's the intent
of the bill is to make it as safe as
possible without going into really into
the weeds and the statute so I think
this covers that that very
well thank you uh represent Morris did
you have a further comment no I just
agree with everything thank you she said
any further discussion on the
clerk Vice chairman
Noble yes representative Terry yes
representative dry yes representative
Freeman yes representative litfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative uh moris yes
representative NATO yes representative
Cornell yes representative Murray yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
bbon yes representative Damon yes
representative kuger yes representative
Snodgrass yes and chairman cordelli yes
17 Ys zero Nays
and would the clerk have a further
motion on the bill I would like to move
Amendment great thank you is there a
second on the OTP representative
Woodcock any further
discussion yeah we we're we're down one
yeah um wait hold up what was the
amendment number 07
43 yeah 1 yes on the amendment
yeah so um we have a motion of otpa did
we have a second I'll second that oh
represent Woodcock thank you I'm sorry y
yeah uh any further discussion on the
otpa for the
bill seen
none whenever you ready Vice chairman
Noble yes representative Terry yes
representative dry yes representative
Freeman yes representative litfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Morris yes representative
NATO yes representative Cornell yes
representative Murray yes representative
Woodcock yes representative Hall yes
representative Balon yes representative
Damon yes representative kuger yes
representative Snodgrass yes
representative cordelli yes 17 yay zero
Nays thank you very much is consent okay
with that yes great thank
you uh next we had a subcommittee on uh
the cellphone bills 781 and 131 I
believe um let's take up uh HB 781
requiring districts to adopt policies
establishing cell phone free
education and uh call on um
representative Lichfield for a motion
I'd like to make the motion ought to
pass please thank you is a
second representative Hall thank you and
um uh uh represent Terry did you have
further motion or discussion uh yes I'd
like to offer an amendment to uh HB
781 uh FN the amendment is um
0733 H that was distributed um a few
minutes ago to all members of the
committee thank you and that's an your
recommending all to pass on that
Amendment oh yes yes sir thank
you uh is there a second to the motion
on the amendment representative Hall
thank you um and I'll just mention uh
the subcommittee was um representative
Terry litfield and
Hall uh representa
Terry further discussion on the
amendment was there a second I didn't
hear it yes represent Paul did uh thank
you thank you uh let me just say by way
of introdu ction um I think this is
sometimes referred to uh as a sausage
making uh I I have made sausage in less
time than it took to deal with the four
sentences in the original
781 uh but found it to be a very
productive collegial uh discussion a
collaborative effort and so I I'm
delighted to uh uh to speak in favor of
of this amendment um just to highlight
uh a couple two or three changes because
I may not get them all um on line nine
of the amendment um we added the
subcommittee added Boards of Trustees of
Chartered public schools in addition to
school boards of public
schools um we also added on line 10 uh
other personal electronic communication
devices in schools because even though
we're no longer in school any of us we
realize that there are other personal
electronic communication devices that
are coming that are in existence and
coming online all the time and we wanted
to be sure that those devices were
covered as well as uh the specific uh
item called cell
phones um if we go to uh line
11 uh the policy shall at a minimum
restrict the use of student personal
cell phones the change here in the in
the original language of uh
781 districts are encouraged to consider
uh such policy shall restrict the use of
certain student personal cell phones
during class instruction without
educator approval uh we want it to be
stronger than encourage because we see
this as such a a terrible problem that
is occurring amongst Our Youth and um
particularly with respect to their time
in in our schools um and so we wanted to
make clear to those who are actually
going to implement this law which would
be the school boards and the boards of
Trustees of Charter Public Schools that
the policy we want to be very clear it
shall at a minimum restrict the use of
student personal cell phones during
class instruction therefore the language
is effectively permissive and
encouraging them to consider other times
during the school day that the local
school board or the chartered the Board
of Trustees of the chartered Public
Schools might want to include such as uh
the lunchroom or athletic fields some uh
just a couple of hypothetical examples
um if we move on we also added the
language in line 12 12 and 13 uh that we
we found helpful from the the governor's
budget
proposal um uh that the
policy um might have approved exceptions
determined by the superintendent or
their designate with respect to student
medical disability or language
proficiency needs we wanted to make that
clear to the school boards and to the
boards of Trustees of the chartered
Public Schools finally the last s the
next to the last sentence School
District policy shall not prohibit
students with medical needs such as
insulin pumps and glucose sensors or
disabilities from using a device to
support their learning as identified by
the IEP plan developed under Section 504
which is quite Broad and inclusive so we
didn't really believe that we needed to
go into a lot of detail uh rather by
referencing and including Section 504 of
The Rehabilitation Act of
1973 those who would be de developing
these policies would need to of course
reference those and then finally we went
round and around on an effective date um
the subcommittee agreed that we would
like to have this policy in we'd have to
have policies in place in our schools
beginning with the next school year
therefore the ACT shall take effect July
1st 2025 we were assured by the school
board's uh uh lobbyist Association
lobbyist that that would be plenty of
time for the uh the bodies to uh to
develop over the summer their policies
and to be able to implement them at the
beginning of the school year um thank
you very much Mr chairman thank you uh
any further discussion on the amendment
representative Hall did you want to
chair
yes
um I I agree with the need for um a
policy um but the more I look at the
restrictions that are outlined from 11
line 11 down um I'm concerned that we
are telling the schools what the policy
will
be 9 10 11 said they need to create a
policy which is their prerogative sort
of like
curriculum then we get down from 11 on
we tell them exactly what's in there
which is not our role in my
opinion thank you thank you
discussion no further discussion on the
amendment uh then um Madam clerk could
you
amendment
okay Vice chairman
Noble yes representative Terry yes
representative yes representative
Freeman yes representative Lichfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Morris yes representative
NATO yes representative Cornell yes
representative Murray yes representative
Woodcock no representative Hall yes
representative B Bon yes representative
Damon yes representative kuger yes
representative Snodgrass yes and
chairman cordelli yes 16 Ys one
nay um representative litfield did you
have a further motion on this Bill yes a
to pass as amended please thank you
second by representative Terry uh
discussion on the
otpa I AG I agree with this and and
opposed to my fellow Committee Member I
I would even like to see it a little bit
stricter because having done lunch duty
I I am concerned with watching to tables
of students on their phones are not
talking to each other and and that just
bothered me a lot and I I'd like them to
have to talk to each other so if
anything
hopefully it could be weaned in a little
bit to make it a little bit
stricter repr would preferably with the
mouth closed while they're talking um
the represent my my concern is not the
policy I think we need a policy I think
that I think the cell phon having been
in the school having been administrator
it's a pain in the neck that being said
I still don't think it's our our right
to delegate specifically what is in that
and similar to curriculum this is a
local option requiring the policy
absolutely by telling every school
system what it has to be without them
taking their own their own uh
prerogative I think that's not our place
thank you thank
you re
Hall Mr chair and to respond to that I
think it does
the school districts with a lot of
options are you going to let them use it
during lunch you going to let them it's
not it doesn't say Bell the bell I think
what we heard out here was a lot of talk
about the Bell to Bell and we we we
considered that and thought Bell to Bell
was letting this telling the the local
folks what to do this basically says you
got to make exceptions to the needs and
during classroom instruction and again
it says personal uh devices so if a
teacher had devices available to all
kids that weren't their personal devices
because you could have a situation where
she has a cell phone she has a cell
phone I don't have one now what you
going to give me a cell phone so I think
it does give them a lot of leeway is it
you know your high school does this your
middle school does this your Elementary
School does this those are all options
available with this language I believe
thank you rent
Noble thank you Mr chair I I think what
we heard out of the hearing is that
they're they don't really want local
control they're looking for the state to
hand down the mandate to make it easier
for them to put these policies in place
so that it's not a fight with parents
and
kids that's how I took it anyway rent
Murray thank you Mr chair um and just
for one point of clarification I just
did want to make sure um that there
wasn't a potential um circumstance where
like classroom instruction where maybe a
scientific calculator would be brought
out for instruction or something like
that um that is a that is an allowable
use of the technology am I correct yeah
I I yes I don't see any problem in that
regard yeah right represent Hall yeah in
response to that I would say it's not a
communication device so that would be
fine thank
you R Terry yes just want to respond to
a couple of the the comments and
concerns that have been
expressed
um a good deal of of the 2 hours and 10
minutes that we spent on these sentences
in this bill was devoted to considering
uh the the delicate balance between the
state being prescriptive in terms of
what must be done and on the other side
um respecting local uh control and and
so that is for example why we um adopted
the phrase at a minimum with respect to
the policy at a minimum we're saying
there needs to be restrictions with
respect
to uh use of these devices during
classroom instruction however local
control with respect to other times
during the day we felt quite confident
that many of the policies would include
um the school lunch room a time but we
uh we we'll be monitoring that and and
seeing how that works out and so I I
hope that's helpful thank
discussion see none um Madam clerk I
think um ready for a vote on otpa on
House Bill
781 Vice chairman Noble yes
representative Terry yes representative
dry yes representative Freeman yes
representative litfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative moris yes yes
representative NATO yes representative
Cornell yes representative Murray yes
representative Woodcock no
representative Hall yes representative
baboni yes representative Damon yes
representative kuger yes representative
Snodgrass yes and chairman cordelli yes
16 y one nay is uh consent okay for that
go great thank you and representative
litfield you'll write the report on that
thank you Mr chair is that du by noon or
one today um yeah the sooner the
better speaking on behalf of our
is uh so the companion
bill um to that was uh House Bill 131
which was uh also related to cell phone
use
um represent Freeman um did you have a
motion on houseb 131 yes I did thank you
Mr chair I'd like to move to retain this
bill seeing as we have um addressed some
of the issues with the last bill a
second uh any further
discussion represent Freeman just
briefly um we we've this is almost a
mirror bill of the last bill we passed
um about cell phone usage so at this
time I think retaining it and um either
giving it further examination or at some
point um voting to um itl it um would be
the prudent thing to
do thank you represent Terry yes uh I'm
in support of uh retaining the bill uh
in case something disastrous unforeseen
and disastrous occurs with respect to
781 uh I would like to to point out um
that in agreement with representative
Freeman that 781 and 131 are are
basically mirror each other um I did not
point out um before that um with respect
to 781 that the fiscal piece the
appropriation was was removed 131 does
not have the appropriation but uh
effectively with the bill that we're
going to be recommending to the Full
House and the bill that may be retained
um if if we do vote to do so um there is
no no fiscal note at this time thank you
thank you any further
discussion uh seen none um Madam
clerk VI chairman Noble yes
representative Terry yes representative
dry yes representative Freeman yes
representative Lichfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Morris yes representative
NATO yes representative Cornell yes
representative Murray yes represent
Woodcock yes representative Hall yes
representative Balon yes representative
Damon yes representative kuger yes
representative Snodgrass yes chairman
Nays thank you very much uh consent is
okay for that one as well
consent oh retain I'm sorry yeah getting
ahead of
myself um next uh let's take up uh how
House Bill
398 um which um was not on the uh list
for today but is a uh an outstanding
bill um that we did talk about but had
not exec yet
uh yeah
right does anyone have a motion for that
uh 39 8 it's a title the title on that
is requiring Holocaust and genocide
studies in public schools to include the
disabilities do you
want uh I'll move
itl thank you very much is there a
Freeman uh is there any uh
discussion yes um representative selig
had checked with the genocide commission
and they believe that this was already
being
covered any further discussion just a
question Mr the chair yes um Vice chair
could you just repeat that again please
thank you representative selig had
checked with the genocide commission um
and they believe that this was already
being covered Holocaust oh I'm sorry
Holocaust commission thank you
right
discussion Madam clerk when you're ready
okay motion is itl vice chairman Noble
yes representative Terry yes
representative dry yes representative
Freeman yes representative litfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative moris yes representative
NATO yes representative Cornell yes
representative Murray yes representative
Woodcock yes representative Hall yes
representative Boni yes representative
Damon yes representative kuger yes
representative Snodgrass yes chairman no
cordelli yes
17 y zero
Nays any objection to consent no great
thank
you
um there were um several bills that we
wanted to uh not address um today and
recess them to uh next
week um they are uh s House Bill
754 um there was an amendment passed
around this morning but um I think
people wanted additional time uh to look
at that Amendment so we will not take
that up
today um House Bill 12 21 related to uh
the parent advisory councils I still
think that we have some work to do in
terms of the formation of those councils
and who is who is going to do that um so
we will hold on that and um uh the prime
sponsor on House Bill 360 had requested
some additional time uh to look at that
bill as well um none of those are early
bills
um so we will um address them um at a
future
session um so let's move excuse me did I
I don't know if I mentioned House Bill
699 um uh I would include um to hold off
on that also because um evidently due to
my error we don't have copies of of
those um and uh I passed out duplicates
of 754 instead so um so uh we'll uh
we'll we I'll try and get copies for
next week of 699
Amendment um so uh that brings us to
House Bill
361 prohibiting mandatory mask policies
and uh if uh she's ready I uh look to uh
representative Noble for a motion on
that thank you Mr chair I move add to
pass thank you is there second represent
moris uh rent Noble would you like to
comment oh just a few comments actually
um this bill doesn't prevent masking in
schools anyone is free to do so they
just can't be mandated for
everyone it was mentioned in the hearing
that it's good that there's a car vote
for IEPs in 504s but the thing is if
this bill doesn't pass there is no car
vote for students with IEPs and 5 4S if
there is a school
mandate um there wasn't last time at
least we know enough now about the
impact on children to be able to do a
proper risk benefit analysis for any
potential Public Health event in the
future just like many of us parents did
from the beginning but there are some
that still don't know that and that is
one of the dangers in leaving this up to
local
control I've read the online testimon
and emails opposing this bill and
there's really no acknowledgement about
how masking affected children and their
education if we were to have another
Public Health Emergency we can't leave
this to school boards to deal with we
can't have them in the middle getting
yelled at by two different sides we also
can't have one District that masks and
another that doesn't local control just
doesn't work in this type of
situation also in um the online
testimony there was a letter from the
Department of Health and Human Services
um the division of Public Health
Services and I'll just read that to you
real quick um Department of Health and
Human Services Division of Public Health
Services is providing the following
information to the education Committee
in consideration of HB 361 relative to
prohibiting mandatory in mask policies
in
schools face masks remain an effective
tool for protect for protecting a person
and preventing the spread of many
infectious respiratory
diseases division of Public Health
Services continues to recommend that
decisions on face mask use be based on
individual choice and informed by a
person's own assessment and acceptance
of risk from currently circulating
infectious diseases rather than from
unversal requirements for
example individuals who are severely
imuno compromised or who desire
additional protection for themselves or
another household member can choose to
wear a face mask for their protection
when in indoor public locations this
recommend this recommended approach to
face mask is also consistent with the
Centers for Disease Control and
prevention updated guidance on mask and
respiratory virus prevention
thank you for the opportunity to provide
this information the department strives
to provide Public Health protection
while appropriately balancing individual
choice and I think thank director watt
for that um
letter and that's all I have I actually
have the letter forgot about
all and that's all I have Mr chair thank
you
uh represent morr did you have anything
to add no any further comment
representative
Hall thank you Mr chair I'll be voting
no on this itl I guess no
um school boards again it is local
control and no one can predict what's
going to happen in the future and I
think school districts School boards can
deal with the IEPs and I have complete
faith that school boards would take that
into consider ation so I I'm voting itl
on this thank you further represent
Damon welcome to education policy again
thank you Mr chair representative DWI D
and I are trying to cover all
bases um I'm opposed to The Spill and I
speak as a healthc care professional now
retired um I would also note in the
online testimony there is a thorough
letter from the New Hampshire Nurses
Association opposing the bill um it is
critically important that we all make
our decisions based in fact and the fact
is situations could be different in
different districts and us on the state
level dictating what should or should
not happen in public health and safety
doesn't make sense I differ respectfully
with representative Noble in that we
should in fact benefit from each
district making the decisions that are
relevant you could have an outbreak of
an infectious disease in Manchester that
isn't affecting the North country or
vice versa the decisions should be made
locally thank
you thank you R Murray uh thank you Mr
chair I too will be voting no on the itl
and I think uh in in addition to
representative Damon's point one of the
things that we saw were a myriad of
different dated dashboards during the
pandemic they came up that showed
various levels of um out um infection
rates and I think that that was a very
data-driven
opportunity to take a look at where um
information was coming from based on
testing results that were coming back
throughout the state and that is
something that I think when we talk
about listening to science that was one
part of the local control aspect that
was very data and science
driven thank you rent
Woodcock thank you um surprisingly to
not I will also being voting no on this
but that being said I think we have
learned from the situation that the vice
chair talks about ways to move forward
in the future and by handcuffing local
schools and not allowing to use what
they've learned it makes no sense to me
um because the board the Health
Community has learned the towns will
learn School boards will learn it's time
to let them do their job with new
information thank you thank you any
further
discussion uh seen n none seen none
uh Madam
clerk this is ought to pass on House
Bill 361 prohibiting mandatory mask
policies and schools Vice chairman Noble
yes representative Terry yes
representative dry yes representative
Freeman yes representative litfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Morris absolutely yes
representative NATO yes representative
Cornell no representative Murray no on
not to
pass representative woodcock
absolutely no representative Hall no
representative bon no representative
Damon no Representative kuger no
representative Snodgrass no chairman
n uh thank you very much
um let me see what else um we
have um house built 286 I think we can
bring up next um which is uh a study
committee to investigate if one one
school superintendent per county is
feasible um representative Freeman did
you have a motion on House Bill 286 yes
thank you Mr chairman I um vote to itl
this bill in expedient to
legislate thank you was there a
second representative McDonald thank you
uh um represent Freeman did you want to
discuss your motion very briefly thank
you Mr chair um while this in theory is
a good idea um I I do believe that we
already have an RSA on the books that
allows for districts to
consolidate um their saus and hence
would um address some of this problem
with the study committee on looking into
whether we should have one school
superintendent or not that and every
county is different um different sizes I
cannot in in good conscience say that
Hillsboro County would be a good example
of having one superintendent so um to
that end I will um ask people to um vote
in expedient to
legislate thank you represent McDonald
did you have anything to yes I would
briefly I agree with representative
Freeman entirely I'll also add that we
have several study committees in law
already it seems needless to me to put
another study committee into law when we
could probably all answer this question
today it's probably not feasible you
mentioned Hillsboro County I would say
where I am and Rockingham County also
not feasible that's not to say I'm
opposed to SAU consolidation but I don't
think this bill is the answer to do that
thank you thank you anything further
I'll just add we have a couple of sa
related consolidation bills uh still to
uh to bring up um I consider this in the
same vein um so um
we want to take a look at those other
two bills um upcoming but they're not
early bills so um you know please take a
look at those and I'll get those
scheduled um for
discussion um in the remaining two weeks
that we
have um if no further discussion Madam
clerk um we're ready on uh House Bill
286 I believe motion is itl vice
chairman Noble yes representative Terry
yes representative dry yes
representative Freeman yes
representative Lichfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative t uh moris yes
representative NATO yes representative
Cornell yes representative Murray yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
bbon yes representative Damon yes
representative kuger yes representative
Snodgrass yes chairman cordelli yes 17 y
zero Nays any objections to consent
much I'll open the executive session on
HB
709 allowing parents or Guardians to
admit their children into any school
district where they pay any property or
School District taxes and I Look to
representative cordelli for a motion uh
thank you uh I would move uh that we
retain House Bill 709 is there a
second representative
Terry representative cordelli any
discussion yes thank you um I think that
there were uh questions raised um about
uh this bill and the uh the
property uh being involved as possibly
second homes
Etc um we do have some uh similar uh
bills related to uh public school
districts uh coming up um so uh I did
talk to the prime sponsor uh of the bill
about retaining this and possibly um
looking at resolving some of the
problems in in the future um if needed
um otherwise we have other options um
for it when it comes uh to uh the time
for retain bills in the fall and the
vote in
January any other
discussion representative Corell thank
you madam chair I I am glad it's going
to be retained because I I don't agree
with it but I will be voting against the
retain because I would rather vote itl
on this so I but I'm glad I'm happy that
it would be
retained any other
discussion seeing none Madame clerk the
motion is to
retain Vice chairman Noble yes
representative Terry yes representative
dry yes representative Freeman yes
representative Lichfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Morris yes representative
NATO yes representative Cornell no
representative Murray no representative
Woodcock no representative Hall no
representative bon no representative
Damon no Representative cler no repres
representative Snodgrass no and chairman
cordelli yes nine yays eight Nays thank
you very much um I believe that takes
care represent Cornell I think that
takes care of all the bills we had
discussed um uh to uh take care of this
morning but um I did want to um it gives
me some time to take care of reports
that uh that I owe um and um a couple of
early bills that we especially need to
take care of um but there are bills from
this morning since we have a little bit
of time um maybe
uh represent Noble could you go over the
reports that would be required maybe if
someone has time to write a report this
morning so we could get them into the
calendar for next week it would be very
helpful me to read it up yes if you
could uh representative drive for HB
781 uh representative Noble for
398 representative Noble for 361 how' I
this and representative Freeman for 286
uh representative Hull for 361 Minority
Report
question with respect to 70 781 Mr chair
since the fiscal section was dropped is
is this now 781 clean or 781 FN with no
FN it it continues that way it continues
even though it doesn't have a fiscal
note right thank
you I'll I'll know that for the next
Jeopardy uh session right um so if if
those people could work on um those
reports um you know we'll see if we can
get them processed by 1:00 and um uh get
them onto the calendar for next week and
save us some work in the future um which
thing yeah yeah great thank you very
much and Mr chairman just to be yes just
to be perfectly clear the this afternoon
indicates executive session on pending
legislation may be held throughout the
day um it appears as though there will
be no pending legislation acted upon but
I just want to be clear do you intend to
have any executive sessions this
afternoon I I do not expect that okay
thank
you I'm sorry I was
talking he just asked if we were going
to exact any more bills this afternoon
and I I don't expect that we will
be so um so if you Mr chair I would like
to thank you for being like that in this
committee and and not doing surprise
exacts I we really appreciate that thank
you yeah you can take thank me after uh
maybe thank you and we'll reconvene at
o'clock I have to do any
be
nice
e
for which it stands one nation under God
all we'll open the public hearing on
non- gerain amendment to hb50 relative
to intentional or knowing violation of
the prohibition on teaching
discrimination and I welcome
representative cordelli the prime
sponsor uh thank you very much um Madam
chairman and uh fellow members of
Education policy for the record um Glenn
cordelli representing tuon Boro wolf bro
and O in the beautiful Lakes Region and
uh this is a a non-gain Amendment uh to
HB 50 um it's the same general topic but
it uh slightly revises the intent of the
original
legislation and that the original intent
was repealing much of uh what was in
statute U both in uh
193 and in the uh human rights uh
section of Statute um Rel ated to the
topic of
Concepts um that some call divisive
Concepts um but uh they were concepts
related to uh I think equal treatment of
everybody um so what my Amendment does
instead is
address some of the uh um rulings by New
Hampshire judge in a casee a lawsuit
that was filed um against these Concepts
in
statute um there was a lengthy uh brief
um that I do have copies of um if
anyone's interested uh but I'll just
touch on U one aspect of the
judge's uh
ruling um and I believe there's someone
here who can uh uh further explain where
the uh case currently
lies um but one of the uh uh areas um
that was uh the basis of the lawsuit was
um vagueness um related uh to um
violations of the educator code of
conduct and what might qualify in that
regard uh so uh my bill intends to
address though that vagueness that the
judge felt was inherent in the law and
um it's not a lengthy uh Amendment as
you can see but Roman 3
and4 addresses violations by adding the
words intentional or
knowing so to be considered in a
violation someone has to knowingly or
intentionally um act in this manner and
uh the
court um ruled that um this was
vague uh in the original
Law um and uh it's uh the vagueness was
um
categorized um it does not include what
was termed a scienter
clause um and uh I can read from the uh
judges ruling which basically quotes
Black's uh Law Dictionary the scienter
is the degree of knowledge that makes a
person legally responsible for the qu
for the consequences of her or his act
or
Omission so this is meant to address
that um and make uh them responsible for
the consequences of their actions by
indicating that the action has to be
intentional or
knowing um and the judge in that New
Hampshire case went on to say the value
of a scienter requirement is that it
limits a laws scope to those who
knowingly engage in a particular course
of
conduct so the entire purpose of this
amendment is to address that concept of
vagueness um in the current law and um
make sure that we know that uh the
intent of the person is intentional or
knowing and that that would be a
violation I thank you very much thank
questions seeing none thank you thank
you
Senate
Murray thank you Madame Vice chair um
for the record my name is Megan Murray I
represent Hillsboro District 37 that is
Amhurst in Milford I am a co-sponsor on
the underlying bill of house bill 50 and
I'm here to testify in opposition to the
it stands to reason that unless the law
is repealed by a house bill 50 that we
have uh that we potentially further
encumber ourselves to litigation around
the constitutionality of of um the bill
and the topic as amended with uh house
bill or excuse me Amendment 20250
059 H
059 95h the first amendment protects
free speech and I'm not sure how this
amendment would compart with both the
first and 14th amendments given that
some sometimes um honest yet
uncomfortable representations of
historical truths could be construed as
quote knowing violations when in fact
they're just facts uh I urge the
committee to vote no on the non-gain
amendment so that uh house bill 50 can
move forward unattached uh repealing an
unconstitutional law thank you thank you
any
questions representative dve thank you
and thank you for taking my question can
you explain to me what is specifically
on Con
stitutional so I think there's a
potential for a conversation around the
constitutionality of of um there being
quote knowing or intentional
representations of fact I I'm not quite
sure how you would determine that um
when an educator is teaching in the
classroom so I I feel like that could
become a very slippery slope where it
could be overly litigious and people
could be uh and districts could be in a
situation where they find themselves uh
consistently in litigation follow thank
you what in the constitution does that
violate so when I was talking about the
First Amendment free speech about on
classroom any other
questions representative courtel so
thank you madam chair so it sounds like
this was put in to clear up the
vagueness but it sounds like an
intentional or knowing violation could
also be considered vague because we
don't
know if it how do you determine that it
was intentional or knowing so that that
could be intent that could be vague also
yes thank you for the question I I
believe so and I think that um that it
further stands to put teachers and
Educators in a position where they're
constantly having to yet again defend um
what is a factual or historical
truth any other questions representative
Terry yes with respect to the the
language that is in view most
immediately um and upon which you have
opined an intentional or knowing
violation would you object to having the
Court rule as to whether that is
satisfies its concern for clarity as
opposed to your opinion being a
sufficient basis not to go forward with
this do you trust the courts to be able
I'm I'm not sure I'm understanding your
question you said earlier in your
opening statement that if we adopted
this amendment that it would open us up
to to unnecessary extended
litigation did you not or I said that
was a potentiality yes do you have a
problem with
that litigation over Clarity of language
law I'm not sure what I'm understanding
that is just a fact of the judicial
process what I am saying is that by
default it could potentially open the
situation up to further litigation
that's all I'm saying uh recognizing
that we're not in the United States
House of Representative I should
probably defer now but I'd love to go on
for another three minutes
thanks thank you any other
questions represent Cornell so thank you
madam chair so if this did go into
litigation who would be responsible for
the cost of the litigation it's a great
question uh I'm not entirely sure but it
it it it would stand a reason that you
would think that um if somebody was
being um implicated in knowing it could
either be the educator themselves or the
district it seems like that's how I was
so the taxpayers of the dist could be
liable for the cost of the litigation
potentially thank
you any other questions seeing none
thank you very much I'm resident Timothy
haran from straford County District
district 10 the town of Durham and I U I
support the underlying bill I uh would
have been happy to be a co-sponsor of it
but um not not one of the names on the
Mast head but I think that's an
excellent bill
19340 um it's very bad law I me aside
from the fact it violates both the
federal and state constitution it's also
bad policy um we need to teach children
about uh about these Concepts what's
sort of has been um you know what's sort
of been lumped at least by some under
the acronym Dei and what I should say
Dei stands for diversity equity and
inclusion and those are three things I
don't think any you know well maybe
diversity but like we're diverse New
Hampshire is a diverse State United
States a diverse Society there's no way
around that and I'm not sure who's in
who's in who who could be against Equity
or against inclusion if you put it that
way but if call it Dei that's different
um and uh me I don't necessarily I'm a
little bit uncertain about uh saying
what's in the Constitution that's
still still being observed and what
isn't but we have a state constitution
which also guarantees the right to
freedom of speech and freedom of
conscience so that's certainly still in
place I mean I trust the courts more
than some other
institutions I would uh but also I say
there's a process issue here which is uh
this bill hijacks you know the non-
gerain amendment it uh completely
replaces a bill and it has essentially
the opposite aim of uh of what the
original bill was at least I mean it
does add this language about intentional
or knowing I really don't know that that
makes the bill any better it doesn't
address um other problems just every sub
paragraph 193 40 has pro has problems um
in ter we're talking about where the
litigation is I me guess anytime you
guarantee people's rights um if the
rights are violated they can litigate
and I looked at it looked at it and uh
so you can either uh you can either
bring it lawsuit in the superior court
or with the commission on Human Rights
Commission on human rights uh has a lot
of structural problems um so we probably
shouldn't be adding any more work to the
commission on human rights and I don't
even I'm not even aware they've actually
like um taken on any cases uh inspired
by 19340 but certainly this bill the
amendment either uh
doesn't doesn't improve 19340 in any way
or it may even actually make it even
bager and it certainly doesn't attack
any of the problems with it so in that
regard it has exact opposite of intent
of what the sponsors intended which was
just to strike this uh strike this bad
statue from the law books well I guess
it did replace it with sort of a general
statement of Ideal so from that regard I
there's huge process problems with the
amendment even though our rules do allow
us to do it and it's uh I think somewhat
disrespectful to the sponsors to do it
especially since U this could have been
attached to some other bills and i' I've
had I've had bills I've had bills
hijacked um in the past to do the
opposite of what I had in mind and uh
you know it's it's part of the game that
we play here it's allowable but it's
really not uh it's not a good t tactic
and uh so it's really my opinion that's
probably not the right way to go about
achieving the same I think it was a
little bit unfair to to do that to the
sponsors especially since there's many
other bills this non-ed amendment could
have been attached to so I would just uh
I just urge you to reject the I hope the
committee will reject the uh reject the
non-gain amendment but I hope they'll
pass the underlying bill so
that's U so that's that's all I have to
say about it so pass the underlying Bill
like reject the amendment and so I'd be
happy to take any questions if anyone
has any but thank you any
questions like represent Morse y thank
you for taking my question here in the
current statute RSA 19340 section 1A it
states teachers cannot teach one student
of whatever race gender sexual
orientation or disabilities that they
are superior to another so if repealing
HB sorry if we're repealing 19340 with
hb50 then wouldn't that unbind teachers
hands allowing them to teach students
that they are minorities and further
propaganda on our students um I not sure
how to not sure how to answer that I
mean they that's something that they
should not have been doing um that was
that was something would have been bad I
don't know of any cases where teachers
are actually doing that um so I probably
think uh if I declined to answer your
question I can point out you'll have an
executive session POS and work side so
maybe you can discuss that with your
fellow committee members Andor if you if
you can find some instances of teachers
doing that maybe you can share that
information with the committee but I you
know that was something was already like
not allowed uh
before um RSA 19340 was was uh rather
hastily passing the law as part of the
uh Budget Trailer Bill 40 years ago so
that's about all the answer I have for
that so thanks any other questions
McKinley thank you chairwoman Noble and
the members of the
committee I am Shannon McGinley I'm the
executive director of Cornerstone action
here in New I'm testifying on Amendment
0595 H to
hb50 Cornerstone is New Hampshire's only
full-time Christian advocacy
organization representing over a 100
churches around the state after the
passage of the CRT law we became the
primary organization in the state
helping parents report violations of the
law unfortunately although we helped
report at least 67 Educators who were
credibly violating the law the
Department of Education did not invest
tigate any of those teachers although
Amendment 0595 does not hurt our law and
we will not oppose the amendment neither
should this committee think that it will
get the law up and running again in the
district judge's ruling and joining our
law the judge's main argument taking up
most of his opinion was that the
substance of our law was ambiguous in
particular the judge said it was not
clear whether the law prohibited
teachers from promoting affirmative
action while we think that the judge's
decision was politically motivated he
did leave us a clear path to get the law
up and running again by directly
addressing this supposed
ambiguity it is true that the judge also
said that the law needed a clear mental
require mental state requirement and
this amendment addresses that however
that was only one very minor part of the
judge's opinion there is no legal
argument that this small change will be
enough to restore the law we understand
that the Department of Justice is asking
legislators not to significantly amend
the current law but it is no secret that
our doj is full of attorneys who
politically opposed passing this law in
the first place and it was the doj that
consistently pressured the Department of
Education not to even investigate any
violations of the law rendering the law
ineffective before it was even
enjoined if the committee wants to to
restore the CRT law as we do I hope it
will seek a second out opinion outside
of our state agencies while I want to
offer the services of our own staff
litigator in crafting an amendment so
far our experience has been that every
attorney outside the doj agrees that
simply changing the mental state element
in this law will not address judge
barbadoro opinion thank you and although
I'm not an attorney I will do my best to
answer questions I do just want quickly
chairman to point out when somebody was
talking about um previously this
question of intentionally or knowing you
know where their mental state was we do
that all the time in law it's not a
unique thing thank you chairman thank
you any questions representative
wock thank you madam chair good
afternoon good afternoon um I just have
a question you said your testimony I
think I get this right okay um that the
doj pressured the Department of
Education not to prosecute this law
that's correct can you give me an
example of that in convers I mean in
multiple conversations that we've had
with people in the doj that that was a
situation it's not it's not there's
nothing public that I can provide you
now so there's
nothing May chair yes follow thank you
so there's nothing that you actually
have to substantiate that the doj
pressured the Department of Education
not to fall through in their obligation
I'll have my attorney follow up with you
and he can share that
information thank you thank you m
here representative
dry thank you thank you for taking my
question um I just want to get this
right it says you oppose the bill but
the
amendment is we just want to be clear
that it's not going to resolve the
concern that we have with the Department
of Education not being able to enforce
it okay follow so the when it says
oppose opposes the bill I want to get
this right correct oppose the under we
Cornerstone opposes the underlying bill
and we would support very much a non
main Amendment but we believe that it
needs to be that this language needs to
be tweaked in order to address the
problem thank you for clearing that up
thank you very much any other questions
oh representative Corell sorry okay
thank you m that was my question I
couldn't tell from your testimony
whether you opposed or supported the
underlying Bill Amendment oh okay yeah
the that as it what we said what I said
in that was that we don't oppose the
amendment as it is but we want to be
clear that it's not going to truly
address the issue that it's trying to
address but it's not going to hurt like
I said in my testimony either thank you
representative Lichfield thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question would you be willing to forward
suggestions to the committee yes
definitely thank
you any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you I have copies of my testimony I'll
pass them out and I'm really sorry about
the blue lines on the side thank you
printer
thank you madam chair um and thank you
to the committee my name is Sam Garland
I'm a senior Assistant Attorney General
at the Department of Justice um I
oversee the civil litigation unit and
have been involved in the litigation
around the underlying law um I'm neither
here in support or or opposed to the
non-main amendment or the underlying um
bill but I'm here to try to provide
technical guidance to the committee and
answer any questions you may have and I
think one thing that that may be helpful
um that I intended to talk about was
just kind of the course of the
litigation to date and where the case
currently stands so I was planning to
start there um and so as representative
cordelli pointed out there was a
challenge to the underlying um law that
was passed back in 2021 in Federal
District Court um we litigated across
several years um and there were First
Amendment challenges and 14th Amendment
bigness challenges a due process clause
a challenge to the law um that that were
litigated both kind of at a motion to
dismiss stage and then after discovery
and a motion for summary judgment um the
district judge ruled um that at least
with respect to curricular speech so the
speech that uh teachers make within the
classroom that wasn't protected by the
First Amendment he left open whether the
bill reached um non-curricular speech
that would be protected by the First
Amendment um but then he did ultimately
rule that the law was unconstitutionally
vague in violation of the 14th Amendment
so there's the there's um a long history
of case law that if a law is to in
determinate for people to understand
what it what it precludes or what it
prohibits um or would allow for um
arbitrary enforcement it can violate the
14th Amendment so that was the basis of
his ruling um he identified really three
different things that contributed to it
I I don't want to say they're unrelated
but three different factors that he um
believed were were what contributed to
the bigness um one was um as
representative Murray pointed out and
this was a big focus of the opinion
really that the conduct that was being
prohibited uh he expressed concerns in
his opinion about those four categories
and whether they were sufficiently clear
um to put a person on notice as to what
was being prohibited but then he also
said um that there were two other
factors of the law that required that it
be more precise than than than ordinary
legislation that' be subject to what he
called a more exacting vagueness
standard and those two things were the
fact that there was a penalty the
educator code of conduct um uh violation
um Can can have lure ramifications and
so there's case law um that he noted
that supports the idea that if there's a
penalty associated with a law it can be
it needs to be more precise um and then
also that there was no men's Rea or
Center requirement and that's that's
what this um this amendment as I
understand it's designed to address that
when a law doesn't have a specific
mental state that's required to violate
it um it it is more susceptible to
arbitrary enforcement it's more
susceptible to to not putting a p person
on notices to how they violate the law
so this particular Amendment addresses
that concern that concern that that um
the judge said contributed to applying a
more heightened uh vagueness standard by
putting in knowing and intent or
intentional which are common um men's
Ray States common uh enter states that
exist in criminal law and in in civil
laws so as I understand it this would
address one of the concerns it it isn't
clear whether that would ultimately
change the outcome of the litigation um
that that's you know it's impossible and
I know this is a lawyer lawyerly
response but I I mean it genuinely I I
don't know if if this bill passed
whether it would ultimately change the
outcome of the litigation but it does
directly address one of the the big
concerns that the judge noted in the law
um in terms of the uh the process the
case is currently on appeal at the US
court of appeals for the first circuit
in Boston which is our appell at court
for um Northeastern states um the
intermediate appell at court it's mostly
briefed and there's an oral argument
scheduled in Boston for um for April 8th
that we'll be we'll be arguing at that
point um I don't know how long it will
take after that for the first circuit
the rule it can be a matter of of weeks
or months it can be the better part of a
year it's an appell at court and we
don't have a huge amount of control over
that um at which point you know however
the court rules um will have more
guidance from a court on whether you
know this panel of three judges as
opposed to a single judge believes that
the law is unconstitutional if the court
believes that it is then you know our
office SW to assess options and and the
next step is the US Supreme Court from
there um so all that all of that's to
say the litigation is ongoing we have
def defended the underlying bill um and
again I'm not here to support oppose
anything as a matter of policy but we I
we we've defended it and we defended it
vigorously in this recort we are
briefing and defending it in um in the
first circuit and this bill this
amendment would address one of the
concerns that the federal judge
identified in the underlying law um and
I welcome any questions that folks have
thank you so you the state is prepared
to fight this in the Supreme Court if it
it doesn't Prevail in first I can't
commit to that here I mean that's a
question that's that's outside of my
authority to answer it ultimately any
sort of appeal has to go through um our
solicitor general and ultimately through
the attorney general and so that's not
something that sitting as you know as a
as as litigation chap I can answer but
it's certainly something anytime we get
an adverse ruling in court our office
assesses whether that's in a civil case
like like I'm involved in a criminal
case as well so I I can't commit one way
or the other to that I know it's a
frustrating answer but that would be the
next step from the first circuit okay
representative Terry yes thank
you uh sir the previous witness
indicated that there were 67 cases or
complaints that were filed by
individuals with respect to the claim a
violation of the
law um are you in a position to be able
to given your position to be able to
tell us whether in fact you can confirm
that any number between 1 and 67 cases
which the previous witness has indicated
that she will supply the committee
details with um any number between 1 and
67 given that you have said that you
will be vigorously supporting the law in
court that seems to run counter to the
claim that between 1 and 67 complaints
that were made or up to 67 complaints
that were made were not acted upon by
the Department of Justice with respect
to its relationship to the Department of
Education is is is is that so in in your
to your knowledge or is does this come
as a a Mis a shock to you today I think
I understand your question there are a
couple different parts to it so if
you'll indulge me I'll try I'll try to
and and if it if if that in fact has any
basis in in truth what would be the
reason to not act upon the complaints
that were filed in a positive manner so
the first the answer the first part of
your question the Department of Justice
didn't doesn't play a specific role
under the statute and in enforcing the
law the the underlying statute has two
enforcement mechanisms one is an
educator Board of conduct um proceeding
before the Board of Education that the
Department of Education brings and the
other is an action either in Superior
Court or the Human Rights Commission
for um for violation of the
anti-discrimination laws and our office
and this is in our briefing um took the
position that that and this this happens
quite commonly when there are two
different um state agencies uh that that
have enforcement Authority that the
process needed to go through the uh
Human Rights Commission first and
ultimately to find a violation of law
before the uh abort of Education
proceeding could could start and that
that's just a a structure of of the law
position that we took and it's it's one
that I think is um is a fair reading of
the underlying law and we represented
that in court in terms of the numbers I
I really don't know sitting here today
um I I I I'm not aware of any specific
number of of matters that was filed in
the board or in the Human Rights
Commission though I know there there
were some and I don't know how many that
was and because the Human Rights
Commission process was kind of the first
step in the process I I I don't believe
that there were any formal Board of
Education matters file but that was
because of the guidance that we provided
in terms of kind of how the process went
to the HRC or to the Superior Court
first and then ultimately went to the
Board of Education um I'm happy to to
provide follow-up information sitting
here today I can't confirm or deny you
know 67 or whatever the number would be
but I did I hopefully that's helpful in
explaining the
process so just be clear to the best of
your knowledge you have not been
involved in any of these alleged cases
or complaints that have been brought by
uh the previous witness indicated 67
individuals that that because of the
process that you've outlined and and how
this how these sorts of things are are
addressed and handled you you have not
even had the opportunity or been given
the opportunity or been requested to be
involved at this point so we the
Department of Justice is not involved in
formally enforcing the law so the
Department of Justice doesn't bring um a
case in the Board of Education I guess
is is the more direct answer to that
question um in terms of what we have
counseled um uh state agencies in terms
of the process I mean we've provided in
our in our written filings kind of the
the two-step process that that I just
explained um I wouldn't be comfortable
going into any kind of anything else
that we've advised agencies just as our
Council representative Hall mad chair
kind of a followup to that those
questions um we heard from the previous
speaker that the doj pressured the doe I
mean those are the that you pressured
the department of Ed can you speak to
that uh I don't want to put words in um
and I I
I I I believe that that the answer to
that question is is how I just answered
the last question which is we did take
the position of how that the process
plays out that it's HRC before it goes
to the um Board of Education because um
and there are credential reasons for
that you don't want two different boards
looking at the same underlying conduct
simultaneously diverting resources and
coming potentially to to opposite
conclusions that that so so the guidance
that we provided was that there was that
it went to the HRC first under um and
then it UL imately went to the Board of
Education um I I I can't speak to any
specific conversations and and I don't I
don't know that I would characterize
that as pressure but I can tell you that
that is that is the formal um position
we took about how the law was to be
enforced thank you any other
questions representative Morris thank
you for my question I just had one
clarification piece you mentioned
earlier about the first amendment being
exempt from classrooms could you just
kind of clarify on that a little bit
sure I can speak to my understanding of
how the judge ruled on that so there was
a question about um the the First
Amendment challenge was uh along the
lines of of teachers being forced to
speak in particular ways or or not
forced to speak in particular ways um
that would violate their their own First
Amendment rights and there's case law
and it's not unique to New Hampshire
that um when teachers are making
pedagogical speech or curricular speech
classroom speech that that's not
protected by the First Amendment there
there's US Supreme Court case law that
that kind of touches on the overarching
issue of official speech versus private
speech and then there's kind of the
downflow of that to the classroom and so
um at the earlier stage of the case in
the motion to dismiss um the the
district judge ruled that and then with
respect to this law that that was true
as well that to the extent it was
affecting curricular speech classroom
speech it didn't implicate the first
amendment that didn't resolve um a
question that ultimately wasn't resolved
because the district judge took the view
it didn't need to be which is to the
extent this law reaches extracurricular
speech whether that is subject to some
protection and whether it would
ultimately create a First Amendment
problem there um you know the plaintiffs
made that argument we addressed it in
briefing but because the judge viewed
the law as unconstitutionally vague um
It ultimately kind of rendered moot that
question so but my answer but to
specifically answer your question it was
um around the first amendment
protections afforded to curricular
speech any other questions
representative Cornell Thank you um you
said that this amendment would address
the third Point's specific mental state
of so that would say any person claiming
so that any person could be my
neighbor's Uncle claiming to be AG
grieved by an intentional or knowing
violation how do you how do you know
something is intentional or knowing I'm
somebody could do something and then
when they asked about that that's not
how I meant to it to come across so how
how do you determine that it was
intentional or knowing I I think you
would uh be better served having a
criminal attorney here because those
that's the um venue where that more
often comes up um but um ult timately it
is it is a question of whether through
direct evidence or circumstantial
evidence you can prove kind of the legal
standards for for intent or the legal
standard for knowing there has been a
fair amount of litigation um around
whether those standards themselves are
vague and and that came up in the
context of this and what our US Supreme
Court has said is that um you know it
isn't it doesn't necessarily resolve the
question in any particular case whether
um whether there is a constitutional
issue with respect to an application of
a statute but when you have those kind
of well-worn Concepts in a law generally
speaking it can it can help protect it
against um a a facial challenge a
challenge that the law is completely
unconstitutional um in all of its
applications which is how the judge
ruled in this case um I I'm guessing
that's not a satisfying answer but but
but the short answer is knowing an
intentional conduct or knowing or
intentional conduct is commonly
something that a Prosecuting entity has
to prove it can be hard to prove you
need to prove it through um director
circumstantial evidence that would
persuade by the standard of proof that
applies that that it's overcome um but
courts have recognized that because
those concepts are kind of inherent in
our Judicial System they and of
themselves don't create a bigness
problem representative
Damon thank you madam chair thank you
for helping us with
this is it correct or not that part of
the role of the Department of Justice
and perhaps
yourself is to advise other agencies
including the department of Ed
when it is appropriate to proceed with a
Judicial
filing in terms of Defending just to
clarified in terms of Defending a
statute like us going into court and
defending it or in terms of when to
bring an action under a statute because
because my rule is to defend has been to
defend our unit to defend a statute to
when it is challenged on constitutional
grounds we aren't the entity that that
would prosecute an action under the
statute if you were going to seek an
educator code of conduct violation or or
or something of that kind I
continue so yes in light of what you
just
informed could you just walk us through
a little bit more how that would work so
that whether it's this statute or I'm
just trying to pull back and get sort of
a broader
picture generally how doj would interact
with other
agencies by way of trying to further
clarify what may or may not have been
pressure from doj to doe uh understood
yeah I the the thing I can't speak to
and and this was an answer in response
to your question to representative Terry
is is any sort of attorney client
Communications because the agencies um
and at times the legislature and at
times the you know the governor's office
are are clients when their um our legal
advice can come up and so I I can't
speak to that and and and but what I can
say generally speaking is that um
agencies come to our office all the time
um asking for for um guidance on on
legal questions
and we have a client counseling unit
it's kind of the counterpart unit to the
one I oversee within the Civil Bureau
that provides legal advice to um two
agencies and that's true of every agency
in the state um in the governor's office
and there have been times when you know
the judicial branch and the legislature
um require uh legal guidance to or legal
representation than the Civil Bureau
does that so um it it's it can be across
the state
government any other
questions see none thank you for coming
Diana
Fenton good afternoon for the record uh
my name is Diana Fenton I'm an attorney
with the Department of Education um I'm
here to answer questions and I don't
really have a whole lot to offer but we
were being mentioned quite a bit so I
certainly wanted to make myself
available here um you know our
understanding the Department's
understanding of the law um and if you
look at RSA 193 colon 40 it starts on
page 561 and it goes on to page
562 but I'll Focus your attention on
page
562 Roman numeral
3 and without violating any attorney
client privilege with the Department of
Justice which I know right now they're
looking behind me going oh please don't
and I promise Sam I won't but if you
look on the doj
website they issued a we call them
technical advisories what do you what do
you call them it was either an attorney
general opinion or frequently asked
questions there you go a really
important document let's call it that
shall we um it's right on their website
and they issued guidance on the
interpretation of this law that's what
the department of Education
followed and I would encourage the
members of this committee to look on the
doj website look at the guidance they
issued that's not attorney to client
privilege and if it is well Sam it's
been violated it's public so um it's
right there on the website and I know
there's been a lot of talk and chatter
about what the department did or
shouldn't have done or 67 cases but the
interpretation of RSA 183 colon 4
was already done Years Ago by the
Attorney General's office and it's
written very clearly in Roman numeral 3
it says any person claiming to be
grieved by a violation of this
section May initiate a civil action
against a school or School District in
Superior Court that's not the Department
of
Education for legal or Equitable relief
or with the New Hampshire commission for
human
rights those two entities were the area
where these cases were investigated and
litigated and in Roman numeral 4 if
there was a finding a violation of the
section if there was a finding that
there had been a violation then and only
then did the jurisdiction transfer if
you will to the Department of Education
imposed now you know I'm no fool so I'm
going to turn around and check with Sam
make sure I got that right ready here we
go Sam we good oh I love when he says
that makes my
day that was the role the Department of
Education played under this statute
that's how the law is clearly written
and that interpretation was supported
and enforced by the doj's I'll call it
advisory opinion but let's just say
really important paper that's on their
website and I would encourage you to
take a look at it that's what the
Department of Education followed oh look
at that you're already ahead of the game
I should have known that's why she's in
charge
um that's the role the department played
in this I'm not aware of the 67 cases I
don't know where that number comes from
I don't dispute it I don't mistrust it I
I'm just not in a position to say
yes that's an accurate number or it's
not because again I want to highlight
the law is clear as written it follows
the interpretation by the Department of
Justice and the department of
education's role in this was limited to
Simply the penalty if there was a
finding from any of those agent uh those
other entities the superior court or the
Human Rights Commission that being said
I'm happy to take any questions and I
appreciate your time I know it's been a
long day already any questions
representative B Bon thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question okay again for clarification if
I had an issue and I thought that one of
these violations had happened in my
school where would I report
it you would report it you would
initiate a civil action in Superior
Court or you would file with the Human
Rights Commission and my understanding
was that the department of education was
receiving a lot of these complaints as
that's understandable as a member of the
general public I would put the two
together we would re-refer them to the
Human Rights Commission and I believe
there was a link on our website you
remember this there's Sam's going to
leave he's he's like I'm G to sneak out
the back door um there was a link on our
website that went directly to the Human
Rights
Commission clarification yes so just
again a clarification
um if I was reporting there was a link
that was on the doe site yes that nobody
at the doe saw it went directly to the
doj no it did not go to directly to the
doj it went to the Human Rights
Commission oh Human Rights Commission
okay thank you that is my understanding
to the best of my knowledge the
Department of Education did not have
access to those there was a link on our
website and it went to the Human Rights
Commission
Sam that web page is there yeah
okay representative
Freeman thank you madam chair and thank
you attorney Fenton for taking my
question so after it goes to the Human
Rights Commission walk us through the
process
please it goes through the Human Rights
Commission it's investigated by the
Human Rights Commission I have no
oversight no I I understand in that
world so I can't get into the details of
that okay if there is a finding if
there's a violation if someone says here
found that there was a violation of
19340 then it would come to the
Department of Education to review and
impose a sanction on the credential
holder license depending on the facts of
that case Okay follow up follow up so
through this process from what you
understand the doj never comes into play
is that
correct are you the one of you anybody
who can answer it I'm good I'm happy to
try to answer thank you for the question
um the doj May have a role to play I
mean we certainly have a role to play in
interpreting the law and I appreciate um
attorney Fen pointing out the uh the our
opinion because that is on the website
and that is the public guidance um we do
have a role to play when we're asked for
to provide legal guidance um to agencies
in terms of how to interpret the law or
how to implement the law and we
certainly have a role to play and that's
the role I play in defending laws when
they're challenged and and we do that
whether we agree with the law whether we
disagree with the law whether um you
know it's it's susceptible to to a
challenge or whe whether a challenge is
is completely meritless I mean that's
kind of the role we play in civil
litigation so those are really The Three
Hats that that we might play uh in Visa
a law like this okay thank you any other
questions representative wock thank you
mam chairman good afternoon ladies
gentlemen attorneys
um Mrs or Miss I don't know the
executive director McKinley of the
Cornerstone said in her written
statement in her Ral statement that the
doj consistently pressured the
Department of Education
not to even investigate any violations I
asked her for example she didn't have
any are you aware of being consistently
pressured uh represent I mean attorney
Fenton of the doj not to even
investigate no I am not thank you sir
may I ask you the same um no I think the
only thing that I'm aware of is is
providing guidance to agencies both
public guidance like what attorney F
mentioned and and guidance that would
subject to returning client privilege
but not something that that I would
understand to be consistent pressure
thank you both very much thank you Mr
chair if if I may I want to give a full
answer to representative Freeman um
there is uh this civil rights unit at uh
with attorney Sean Lock um so I know
that the Department of Education when
these cases would come up we would refer
them to the Human Rights Commission as I
previously testified to but we have also
reached out and work very closely with
sha lock if an issue comes up um we will
refer it to to him for consideration he
might then pass it on to the Human
Rights Commission so there's a lot of
back and forth with these state agencies
um and and I think to representative
woodcock's uh question about pressure it
really is very collaborative um in terms
of our our working relationship whether
it's with the Human Rights Commission or
the Attorney General's office it is I
have found in my experience it's a very
collaborative issue and so they produced
their technical sorry technical
advisory you call it again there there
were two different if just to clarify
there were two different there was an
attorney general opinion and there were
frequently asked questions that were
released jointly between the
agencies
so we have had an ongoing rapport with
the Human Rights Commission as it
pertains to these cases and the Attorney
General's office as it pertains to these
cases but the guidance has always been
very clear that the investigative part
of it is handled by the Human Rights
Commission or the Civil Rights unit of
the Attorney General's office maybe I
don't know I can't speak that and then
and then if there is a violation it
comes to the Department of Education so
I hope that helps to better um better
answer your question I didn't want you
to think that we just bypass the
Department of Justice because we work
very closely with the Civil Rights unit
there and I I thank you attorney Fenton
um please don't take this the wrong way
but it's still as clear as mud so I
think you know you you you've definitely
made it clearer but I I I do think that
there are areas where it's still a
little fuzzy and a little gray not for
me because you just sat here and
explained it to me but for the general
public who may not know how to you know
negotiate this system so but I
appreciate the fact that you both sat
here and just walked us through the
whole thing I appreciate that and and I
will just say representative Freeman I
have spoken with a lot of really smart
attorneys that I hold in very high
regard and they have said to me so what
happens who does what I I think it was a
very
confusing situation I can't say I found
the law confusing but just the the
Dynamics that it created and so I
certainly will say that I appreciate the
Attorney General's office releasing
their opinion or frequently asked
questions that that did provide a lot of
guidance not only to the department of
education but also to the field as to
what agency is to do what role
so that was very appreciated I do
appreciate thank you representative
Terry so I just want to be um clear I
realize we're not engaged here in a
Therapeutics or fixic session but think
of thinking thinking of this in terms of
a
flowchart if somebody were to
mistakenly um attempt to file a
complaint with the doj then it's my
understanding the doj would refer the
person to the Department of Education
the Department of Education would then
inform the individual you have two
courses of action you can file with the
Human Rights Commission or you can file
a case in a civil case in Superior Court
and that would be the correct place now
somebody might get it right the first
time if they happen to know the law but
if they didn't know the law and they
either went to the doj first or they
went to to you at the Department of
Education ultimately where that person
would be directed would be to the
provisions that are laid out the
requirements that are laid out in
statute correct yes yes this is like
rules for dummies so thank you oh no
that's the only those are the only rules
I know are the ones for dummies but yes
we we found ourselves in a position
where we
were routinely re-refer these matters to
the Human Rights Commission or to the
Civil Rights unit at the Attorney
General's office
can't
hear can't
hear it
is it is on but hello there I'm back
that what happened oh so it said on that
paragraph on three section three again
it says there's two ways to do it and
you you've referred to it and we've
talked a lot about um if it the link
came in and then it would be sent to uh
the New Hampshire commission for human
rights but the other way uh would would
that does that mean that the um the
parents or the aggrieved individual
would would file a civil action
independently against the school and the
school the state would not be involved
way um I think you're talking about
Roman numeral 3 correct um so yes so
there there were really two options for
enforcement there and um and I just want
to clarify an answer I provided earlier
which was respect with respect to the
board of education for for a direct
action either in the Human Rights
Commission or um Superior Court it was
any person who who claimed to be
aggrieved by the law or or the Attorney
General's office could do that in the
same way that the Civil Rights unit
enforces laws under um under uh
354a but so so yes any person could go
into into court and do it in that way um
it's the board of education process that
then comes after that as attorney Fenton
was talking about that that once there's
been a found violation then a board of
education action can go forward before
the
board
hello so do you know if um we talked a
lot about you know that that nothing
really happened the other way there
weren't any violations or any cases
filed but the first way if they went to
Superior Court do you know of any
instances or attempts of of of not
attempts um filings that went through
Superior
Court agreed by the law um ultimately uh
the the federal judge declared the law
unconstitutional so at this point it's
not enforceable light that order so none
of those timately came to any fruition
I'm not sure if there was B prop cause
that representative
Lichfield thank you madam chair and
thank you for taking the question so if
I'm understanding correctly the judge
ruled that there are three areas of
vagueness the this amendment covers the
addresses the third issue but the first
issue um conduct that is being
prohibited and then the second penalty
needs to be more
precise do you have suggestions on what
we can do to approve improve this
amendment or I realize that we may be
catching you on the spot is this
something
that oh is it not a question I I I don't
believe that they can give us
suggestions on how to change oh sorry
although we would like you to do our
work for
us any other questions IDE yeah seeing n
coren good afternoon uh my name is Lori
coren I'm a state rep in uh Coos 7 but I
want to testify today just for myself
not for my constituents um there was a
time four years ago I was contacted by
one of the parents up in the north
country and one of the teachers at the
local high school was um she's a
language arts
teacher and she was they were reading a
book and the book included um Christian
missionaries go in and
go into a tribe or something and
whatever happened anyway um she wrote on
the board um Bible thumping
crackers to refer to the Christian
missionaries she then continued to refer
to the Bible thumping crackers or B T
C's um as that word now this parent
actually gave me pictures of her writing
this on the board uh she also had a
video of the teacher referring to the
Christian missionaries
as the b
word this parent came to me asking for
help I had no idea what to do I did end
up sending letters to each of the school
board members to the principal to the
assistant principal um and I was
stonewalled the entire time um one of
the superintendant actually said she
would get back to me she did didn't um I
wrote back probably about 4 days later
um and I said you know this the the
parent who sent me this her child isn't
comfortable in class anymore they they
were a Christian family um
and they refused to help I kept asking
you know what where can I send a letter
plus the pictures plus the videos um I
think I think things like this um um are
necessary um I would love to say all
teachers are there just to
teach but there's a lot of ideology
that's getting in it and it and it is
making kids uncomfortable and no family
should have to send their child to hear
that you know Christian missionaries are
the b word um I think a bill like this
is important that's all thank you any
questions
representative Morse just to clarify
you're against the original bill but for
the
amendment I am for the amendment no
yes thank
you
yeah is there anyone else who wishes to
speak on this
time
are
ex representative
please is citizen legisl I me staff here
sign unfortunately I didn't know where
you put it though is it over here is
oh forgot to give me
my I just want to wait a a few minutes
to start the next hearing cuz he's going
to check on the microphone so that we
did
you
hello testing one two three testing oh
hello oh one two
three four
five6 okay he just said I'm number one
thanks did you turn it on work hello
hello can you so am I number one yeah am
yeah hello yeah you
worked
hi
hello
goodbye can you hear
testing
testing hello hello hello anybody in
there
hello
Pronto fronto
okay I'll let Media know we had some
glitches but they might be able to come
in okay once we're finished today yep
prto
prto we'll open the hearing on HB 695 FN
relative to school district school
districts and medically related grants
and I welcome the prime sponsor
representative Perez thank you good
afternoon uh for the record my name is
representative Christine Perez um
Rockingham 16 representing the town of
London daring
last time I'm before you this year um
this is a very simple bill um and I have
submitted an amendment to you the
amendment only changes um words from
school to sto school districts and from
um a legislative body to the
municipality of a of a school so
basically um this is to require the
school districts to form a policy to
adopt a policy um concerning the
acceptance of Grants or seeking grants
for medical products or services or
funds um that unless the town votes in
favor of it once again this clarifies
guidelines for in School Employees and
make sure that families are aware of any
such uh procurements that are being um
in that are in the schools and you can
ask why um well there's several reasons
why um parents in the community should
be aware of such services and have the
option to approve or not approve it and
schools are typically not in the
business and should not be in the
business of Health Care um in
circumstances for their own protection
um the only health care provider that
you really have in a school would be
your would be your school nurse um
grants usually have an end date on them
at which time um the money needed for
the continuing the service or the
um procurement of such things would fall
onto the taxpayer so therefore um they
should be aware of a grant um I can
equate this to it when you ask for a
three-year Grant to bring on perhaps a
new um safety a police officer once that
three-year Grant is done then the um
salary and for that falls on so people
should be aware of um any type of grant
for that reason I really have nothing
else to say about it it's fairly simple
but I'm more than willing to take any
questions representative Morris thank
you and thank you for taking my question
my only question here is regards to
First Aid um aeds and uh like epipens
and we passed a bill recently about
epinephrine injectors would this also in
essence prohibit those types of Grants
from being made unless the school body
go ahead yeah unless the school body
approves
um I'm going to be honest with you I
don't know um I think as far as um your
aeds those are donated usually um I know
our fire department donates them to to
them as far as um actually medication I
don't believe that this would fall under
medications would fall into this but I'm
not exactly sure to be honest with you
representative Hall Madam chair and
thank you for taking my question can you
I'm trying to figure out where this came
from like what precipitated this idea
that this was
necessary
um I actually was asked by a couple of
other legislators to do this in other
towns where there had been issues and um
I I'll go I'll go all the way back okay
where I think part partly this came from
during covid there were multiple school
districts that were an thinking of or or
talking about bringing in um providers
to um offer vac the vaccine for kids um
I know my district was looking into
doing in that too um I know it was it
was stopped in a lot of them um there
are several towns in New Hampshire that
actually cities I take it back cities in
New Hampshire right now that actually
have um medical facilities within their
um comp within their schools um I know
Maine is having a big problem with that
as far as lawsuit suits are going on
because of that because of um lack of
Parental uh notification about what
services in those
um inside the school are being offered
by actually it's uh mostly hospitals are
that are actually putting them in
there's uh lots of lawsuits going on
right now in Maine that were brought to
our attention so I think it is for the
protection um schools are not not in the
healthcare um that's not their service
their service is education um your
health care providers in the school are
nurses there are strict strict
guidelines on what a nurse can do
there's strict guidelines about what a
social worker can do within a school so
I think that this
is you protection for the parents
protection for the children but I also
think it's protection for the school so
that if something happens within the
school because of something being
brought in that is not directly related
to its it's what it's supposed to be
doing it opens it up for lawsuits
so does that answer your question one
second um okay the question is um yeah
yeah I did actually answer my question
um you did say that this is it's okay
unless the town votes in favor correct
how does that happen a warrant warrant
sure we for any every single anything
any Grant you have to have a warrant
number representative may ask where
you're from both both well do you have
if you're getting a new PR a new police
officer do you have it on the warrant
article to accept it okay I'm sorry is
that inappropriate not questions are
going in this direction okay sorry um
yes it would go on the warrant article
um it would go on the warrant to article
to accept the grant similar to if um the
town received a grant for um you know
three new police officers for three
years that type of thing that's right I
think that's the clearest one thank
thank you repres Woodcock thank you m
chair I I just a
clarification you're talking I
understand about are you addressing the
amendment as well
because the amendment's different and I
I hear you Crossing back and forth to
some of your language the amendment is I
do not believe that the amendment is
different the amendment says uh well it
changes it from schools to school
districts so which was a clarification
because it really should say districts
because it would be the entire District
voting on the Grant and it changes the
words of um poorly put that it would be
the um legislative which is a
legislative body of the school district
which is the people in the school
district to um the um citizens of the
municipality M chair may follow follow
well it's I can see what you're saying
but it's the reverse the bill says the
municipality the amendment says the
school
district right well it does not the the
CI you have the bill the citizen right
I'm sorry that's why I'm get
I I apologize I apologize that's okay
you keep on Crossing back and forth I
apologize so the the the the it's the
legislative body of the school district
I was told that that would be better
wording than um the other wording the
initial wording I apologize now we now
we know where we are I apologize that's
okay that's okay I make it all the time
it's been a long day across the hall
yeah but it was the the um so going back
if I may go back to that just I sort of
on two parts
at the conclusion of the amendment you
said line 7 and8 unless the moving to
the last four or five letters u the
school district votes in favor of the
proposed action so basically there's the
first part of the amendment says no
unless the school district that would be
the I'm guessing the school board
because they they're the legislative
body of the school district the school
board is the legislative body of the
school district this no this needs to go
before the town it doesn't say that it
says unless the legislative body of the
school district votes in favor I'm sorry
I'm crossing my wires again yes it needs
to be approved by the legislative body
of the school district which would be
your school board okay so I apologize
that's
okay yes my chair May
finish you may have another question P
the same question just try try to get
the right the right words okay Goa so
back so in that case if they vote one
way or the other they can over take it
right so I wanted to go back to my
original question which was the medical
products um they can't apply for Grants
or accept grants we just have dialogued
this last session and even now this year
on epipens right and generic ens yep and
they're not free they're gr funded so
for the most part so this the F
beginning this would say they can't even
apply for it no it's saying that they
they cannot acceptance of
medical products they need to unless the
school board may I chair yes okay going
back to the I'm going back to the now
let's go back to line six it says a
policy prohibit School dist from seeking
grants so they can't apply if they can't
seek they can't apply you understand I'm
saying it says you can't seek it says
you cannot seek or accept Okay seek or
okay you cor Murray thank you madam
chair um thank you for taking my
question so in the event that um a
school nurse would want to pursue an
opportunity to uh even just look at
potentially like Band-Aids or some other
type of of need within uh their charge
um you're saying that first it would
need to be fully approved by the school
board to even pursue that versus
reaching out to the superintendent or
the school board um many times there are
processes within a district um if you
are um looking uh to have a grant
fulfilled in some way you fill out a
form uh the administrators take a look
at that um so you're saying that that
process would not be in place unless the
school board would approve each
individual
instance it's my understanding that
right now schools do not have
policies around procuring even Band-Aids
okay this is to prevent going from
asking for Band-Aids to asking
for things that would go beyond far
beyond
the treatment of a bruise it's going to
say if we say you don't need anything
that you can get grants for anything
okay with without anybody's approval
okay we can go from Band-Aids to having
an approval to have a medical to
having a medical facility within without
the approval it's to bring it together
so that there's oversight on things that
are being brought into the school that
are Medical in
medically bound not educationally bound
representative Marie Madam chair so your
is it your is it your assertation or
belief that there is not a process
currently at all
for Grants no I think there is might be
a process for Grants but for medical
grants I'm talking about we need to make
sure that there is a strong policy for
medical grants because we do not want I
believe schools getting in the business
of medical
treatment representative
Freeman thank you madam chair thank you
representative for taking my question so
this only applies to Grants this does
not apply to regular medical first aid
than representative bbon thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question um is your opinion that this uh
Medical
Services um would include mental health
Educational Services Psychological
Services um a lot of those are provided
under federal grants to the schools they
are but it's my understanding that they
still have to the grants still have to
be
approved everything should be approved
so that people are aware of what is
going on in the schools I was an
intensive care nurse for intensive ER
nurse recovery room nurse for 42 years
there is a huge difference between
education and medic Med and
medical issues this is to protect
parents teachers staff and students from
things being brought into the school
that may step over a line of what is
school representative
Damon thank you m excuse me thank you
madam chair thank you for taking my
question I actually have
two does this or would this apply to
grant funding from a state agent for
example from the Department of Health
and Human Services might have grant
funding available for some aspect of
medical products or
services so does this apply to Grants
from any entity including state or
federal
absolutely okay
um I have momentarily forgotten my
I'll representative litfield
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking the question
so originally I was excited because I
had thought that you were saying that
you wanted this to go before the
legislative body as in the voters
because so I I my question is I just
want to clarify because my feeling was
that's great because so often we get
these large grants and then when the
grant runs out all of a sudden we're
expected to absorb these into the budget
and it it could be six figures or more
corre so I just want to clarify do do
you mean just the school board or do you
mean the actual legislative body that
votes let's say at deliberative session
or at the school district meeting I had
originally put it in as the citizens of
the
municipality I was
advised I was advised that in order to
make it more palatable I'm being honest
with you that it should be it should be
the legislative body of the school book
I know I it's
called bringing it to make it more
palatable follow up yes please thank you
and thank you I just want to clarify
because I'm wondering if if maybe an
amendment is order in order so you're
you're saying as representative Freeman
asked that um they could apply for
grants that has anything to do with
emergency supplies emergency medical
there you can't apply well not so you do
not want them to be able to apply for
emergency
supplies okay wait a minute
so already okay
one question at a time may I tell you a
story about Maine what's happened in
Maine no
okay I I'm trying to protect I I
literally my intent is Honorable and it
is to protect representative right hold
please State your point please Madam
chair was there a question related to
was this a request of any of the
membership
here what I'm sorry the bill the no the
story where was it in response to a
question that was just asked I thought
we were talking about the amendment or
correct do you have a question
representative moris uh thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question uh in earlier in your testimony
you also mentioned about the things that
are happening in various States and this
would be kind of more of a proactive way
to stop stuff like that from happening
you mentioned specific to Maine and some
of us have heard what is happening in
Maine and would you like to clarify a
little bit about that Maine it's my
understanding that Maine has in several
areas they are actually having different
hospitals putting clinics within the
schools and the story that some of us
heard during um was the story about um
group of young girls 15 going and saying
okay let's all get birth control nothing
B matter with that it's legal but the
problem is is that the pharmacy preside
Pro provides it the parents don't know
which is legal and they had a case and
there's been other cases but the one
case that's struck in my mind is that a
young girl um had an an injury that
required surgery and no one knew that
she was on any type of birth control and
Sen pz
yeah tell the story could we just talk
about grants please
okay sorry I thought he wanted the story
sorry any other questions representive
Corell thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question in the
methodology um this said this could
affect federal grants also yes and so um
in 2425
our federal grants totaled $116
million so in effect if we don't get
these federal grants does not that cost
of providing Services fall to the
taxpayer in the local
community do we get grants specifically
for medical products I I I really am not
clear of what you mean by medical
services and medical products anyway so
I I think that if the Department of
Education said this could impact feral
Federal programs idea Title One Title 1
C Title 1 D mckenny vinto which are affs
homeless people if we're going to lose
$116
million I do not believe that is the
intent of this the intent is at at the
school district level to protect the
schools representative Woodcock thank
you madam shair um I just want to go
back to represent P I appreciate you
your your testimony the other day
particularly your background emercy
Services was really valid but in this
particular case I'm concerned where um
protocols in schools uh having been in
the school business for almost 40 years
too many almost to many years her um
that I've never seen a
grant uh
submitted without approval of the
superintendent in the school boy I I
heard you use the term strong policy
local school boyss have those policies
i' and I've never I've been I worked in
Maine in New Hampshire Massachusetts uh
and never ever have I seen a grant come
from a
teacher or or a a school administrator
without going to superintendent and then
being approved by the school board
different from seeking Grant or looking
for money additional monies so are you
aware of any grants in New Hampshire
where they bypass a superintendent
bypass the school board and and gone to
directly to I've never seen it 40 Years
thank you
no I haven't seen that but I also was
shocked as when I was here before that
there was no policy for emergent care so
these are medical grants these are not
educational
grants and your your superintendent and
all are and teacher and superintendent
Schoolboard are not
necessarily medical people they are
Educators mostly but not necessarily
medical it's separating the educational
Grant from a medical
Grant oh just just my point my point was
not that it's separating anything
because the process is every single
Grant has to go through the school
board I I think in reality you're
talking about
Services the intent of the bill was to
identify services that may or may not be
happening in some schools that you
believe happening during the day but
that but the the rest of this is really
confusing what you're trying to get to
because you're you're rting schools and
you're putting process already in place
you understand me are we sure they're in
place thank you thank you sh
representative
Damon thank you madam
chair so in the past like 25 plus years
ago
probably a local
hospital um in my
district opened a clinic to provide
preventive health care and well ESS care
to teens and they leased space from a
public high school to do that the school
had space not being used the hospital
wanted to bring Services more
conveniently to where the students
generally
are that particular Clinic doesn't exist
anymore um but I think that's not an
unusual model in many
states yes um thank you um so how would
this proposed legislation impact a
clinic run in a school facility but not
run by the school so the hospital or
other entity medical providers are
simply leasing the space and then they
grants if they're leasing the space they
would certainly need to be able to get
approval correct
approval for the lease approval to have
the space within the school and for the
yes I can't ask a question clarification
okay I'm going to be perfectly honest
with you we should not be having medical
facilities within the schools that
should not be happening in my opinion
having been in medical facilities so we
should not be having them in the
schools schools are for education in my
opinion
I want to stop us from running into
trouble talking about
grants any other
good afternoon Madam chair I almost said
good morning how this week has been so
crazy all of you uh thank you for
hearing my testimony today for the
record I'm Becky Wilson from the New
Hampshire school boards Association um I
have not seen the amendment so I cannot
speak to the language of that um I am
going to ask a couple of clarifications
oh thank you representative much
appreciated uh regarding the original
bill and I will try to doubly read and
ask questions about the amendment as
well or I bring up concerns um our
reading of this bill I I think in its
interpretation at least the original
bill this absolutely would impact
District's abilities to procure things
like epipens Naran aeds um and even
still I do believe supplies potentially
for the nurse's office or for um jump
kits or you know those things that you
take in an emergency situation the
buckets Etc um CPR courses or post con
impact testing uh line five does say any
related money is procuring medical
products or services so funds to procure
them that's any funds I believe um it
does it says or funds so it doesn't say
and um I'm not I'm not sure I realized
that may not have been the intention of
the sponsor of this bill to cover all of
those things but I believe the way that
it's written in line five that it would
certainly impact all of those things not
just grants um I share the concern
around the wording of um it shall
prohibit schools from seeking grants so
I'm not sure um how a district would
turn off their ability to seek a grant I
mean you we are constantly getting
information from the Department of
Education for example uh from other
partner organizations who potentially
are putting out information about grants
that could be available to school
districts uh I don't know how don't then
pot you just I guess ignore those emails
and documents coming from the Department
if you don't if you're not allowed to
even seek them out or to get more
clarification about that it's a little
bit concerning that that wording in
there uh I also share a concern about
the fact that this seems to be stating
that you could not accept or even apply
for a grant unless the voters vote that
that you can do that that typically is
in March so what happens if a grant
opportunity comes out in August um and
the deadline to apply for that is
October then the districts are just not
applying I would imagine or they're
going to wait till next march to ask a
question that's irrelevant at that point
um would you call a special meeting I'm
not sure how that would exactly play out
um I will just I I won't go down the
rabbit hole however I will speak to this
issue about the the programmatic
concerns from Maine um that specific
Grant is called Community Schools Grant
I think we've spoken about that in
regards to a different Bill however that
Grant was put into the main state budget
by the main legislature for five schools
to participate so that is why those five
schools are seeking those grants um it
was a legislative action that was taken
by their legislature to try to build
those Community Partnerships within
their state I so it's very specific
however it also Community Schools cover
24 different things that are they are
bringing to the school district of which
one is a primary care service model in
partnership with local Health agencies
so there's 23 other things that come
with Community Schools that is not
solely about medical services in
schools um and just to clarify New
Hampshire I think currently has four
Community Health Partnerships or
community health organizations that are
I think to the previous speaker comment
for lack of a better term renting a
space in a school district to provide
convenient Primary Care Services to
families who are using that as their
Primary
Care um servicer uh I believe those are
summersworth Newport Manchester and
Rochester they are Partnerships with
hospitals or other medical entities they
are not run by School staff as I think
we talked about in other bills
um I do have a question about whether or
not this would impact the district's
ability to accept funds even from our
State Department of Education that is
the flow through for Federal grant
monies that potentially could be tied
back to some sort of medical service or
product um does this affect medically
necessary services that are being
provided at school for students through
idea that fall under Medicaid to schools
would that mean that we could not as a
district participate in Medicaid to
schools what it mean we can't take idea
funds from the flow through at the state
level to cover students medically
necessary services like occupational
therapy or speech um and just to clean
up the fact that um there's a concern
that when grants go away districts have
to hold the bag for whatever they've put
in place certainly that is always a
concern I think we've heard a lot about
that over the last couple of years in
regards to the Esser funds because that
was such a big influx of funds to
districts um that we knew was going to
go away um there is a criteria in almost
all federal grants called maintenance of
effort where the district has to
consider what portion of those services
that you're obtaining with the grant you
are going to put into your operating
budget at the start in order to maintain
your effort to continue to provide those
Services it is not fair to families or
students or staff to give them something
and then just blanketly take it away
when that money runs out so that
maintenance of effort is something
that's required in almost every single
Grant application um and it is meant to
be protective to the district and to the
families of the district so that that
Cliff doesn't happen and those services
that you've been providing don't just go
away on the um positive outlook that
those services are being helpful to
students and families so I'm happy to
take any questions thank you
representative Murray thank you madam
chair um thank you for taking my
question my question is around sort of
that Grant process in general is it is
it a common practice first to um
if if an if a nurse or any other entity
is is Seeking a grant they would first
go to the superintendent and discuss the
desire to seek a grant uh thank you for
the question representative there are
multiple kinds of Grants I mean
obviously you're there's grants that are
obligated to you from the Department as
the flow through things like idea Title
One your title grants Etc um those
typically don't um have re-approval
every single year you know that that
money is coming you know what you're
going to be given by the state and so
those have a somewhat different process
I would say um competitive grants are
something different where obviously
those are put out on an ongoing basis by
lots of different organizations um in
which case yes if anybody at a school
level is looking seeking out a grant it
is almost never that the school can
submit the grant without some sort of
approval at a higher level whether
that's the superintendent and the school
board on the School Board would have to
vote to accept those funds at some level
uh if they were to give be provided the
competitive Grant if they win the grant
um you know all of those things have to
be accepted in terms of school board's
ability to manage federal funds there
and other kinds of funds there are um
priority policies that are required by
law um in New Hampshire policy daf
administration of Federal grant funds
walks you through exactly how those
funds need to be managed at the board
level um and there is also a policy that
is mandated by law uh jlc which is in
regards to Emergency Care at school and
what to do and what school boards can
and cannot do what staff can and cannot
do in regards to an emergency medical
situation um and to try to you know put
the minds of some other people's at ease
that it's very clear what a school board
or a school staff can do in an emergency
situation in terms of medical care and
things like that
any other
savini good afternoon thank you for
hearing my testimony for the record my
name is Emma savini I'm the children's
Behavioral Health policy coordinator at
new Futures new Futures is a nonpartisan
nonprofit organization that solves
problems through policy change we are
here in opposition to House Bill 695 as
written just because of a few um
concerns we have with the language um
specifically that medically related is
not defined um to one of your points I
can't remember who brought it up um it's
unclear to us whether or not this um
involves Med Mental Health Services that
are often Grant funded and really do a
lot of work to partner parents with the
schools in connecting them to Services
outside of the school um in a situation
where we have a huge Workforce crisis
and parents are facing really long wait
lists it's helpful to have um those
services available to students both in
school and out of school when parents
need the services for their
child um the other component to this
that we're concerned about is the
prevention piece there are State
organizations um the governor's
commission that have grants that go I
believe to schools for prevention of
substance use and other risky behaviors
risky Health behaviors um so I think
it's important to make sure that those
Grant dollars are still available for
programs that uh students parents and
schools rely on um happy to take
questions thank you any
you is there anyone else who would like
to testify on this
bill and we'll close the hearing for HP
95 wait what time is it we have
one why did I think it was three yeah
two
e
we'll open the hearing on House Bill 324
FN relative to prohibiting obscene or
harmful sexual materials in school and I
welcome the prime sponsor representative
cordelli uh thank you madam chair
uh for the record Glenn cordelli
representing tson Boro wolf bro and oopy
in the beautiful Lakes
Region
um some of you who are here last term
might remember uh this legislation from
last year um is basically the same
legislation and I think it
is needed
legislation uh because what we've seen
around the nation but also here in New
Hampshire um and I just I happened to
see this one story the other day
um uh a main sixth grade student 11
years old uh testifying at a school
board meeting about a pornographic book
he found in school
library and in his testimony he said the
librarian asked him if he wanted a
graphic version of the book
um that's an example of why we need this
legislation and this
legislation addresses age appropriate
and materials that are harmful to minors
in
schools and there are three basic
components uh to the uh to the
legislation the first is section one at
the
top um which is our Criminal
statutes uh
650 uh statutes in particular right
now uh educational
institutions are exempt from our
obscenity
laws um let me just mention that
obscenity is not protected by the First
Amendment um that was the Roth versus
United States uh Supreme Court decision
7 this
legislation um Alters that exemption to
maintain an exemption for higher
education but not K12
education um the second section really
deals with the
harmful um materials to Miners and the
definitions uh these definitions are Tak
um
from Court decisions um originating with
New York penal
law um and
uh there are definitions on the first
page and over on the second page um
you'll see the definition for when
materials are harmful to minors that's
in Roman 2 on page
two uh again this is been held upheld by
the US Supreme Court and is in um 20
USC code
also and I think that's very important
and I'll just mention um that uh I
worked with the new yor excuse me the
New Hampshire attorney general um on
this legislation and these um def
definitions the third main component to
this uh Bill uh starts on line 20 on
page two uh excuse me now I might be
looking at a different version than you
are but it's um uh
18976 the complaint process it should be
on the second page as
well um and this lays out a minimum
requirements uh for
complaints um we have have so much in
statute about parental involvement in
education um it's right at the top of
our statutes um on
education um and parents need a way to
address the situation when they find
materials that are harmful to minors and
this lays out the minimum process
starting with uh complaints to the uh
principal
then um appeals when necessary um to the
superintendent and to the school board
which is um over on page
three and finally the um uh parent if
they uh have not received satisfaction
at that level they can appeal to the uh
State Board of
Education which is their um right under
existing law elsewhere that is just been
referenced here um in
that uh RSA 21 and 11 under the duties
of the school board uh Roman 3 says Hear
appeals and isue decisions which shall
be considered final decisions of the
Department of Education of any dispute
between individuals and school
systems so this is a right of parents to
continue their appeal process up to the
State Board of Education per
law um and there are time frames um
provided for um each of those steps in
the
process the uh fourth
section of the
legislation is
18977 and enforcement and penalties and
this is a civil
section um in my discussions with the
attorney en he admitted that it would be
very very rare for a situation to
escalate um in a school to a a criminal
uh
case um so we added this civil
section um and I'll just say generally
you know my thought that um if there is
uh no enforcement in legislation it's
really just a
suggestion so we have this enforcement
uh
mechanism under two conditions can a
civil um case be launched and that is
when um the decision of a school or
School District or the school board has
not been adhered to so if the
superintendent says yes this is age
inappropriate should not be in a Middle
School uh move it to the high school or
um this shouldn't be in our schools at
all um if that is not heered to uh the
uh parents would have uh civil
action the other option is that
when
um basically similar to that um in that
the um material is made available to the
minor in a matter that's not consistent
with the final decision
um in either case the petitioner could
be warded uh general or special damages
by the civil
is
reasonable legislation based on uh all
the instances um we have seen um many of
you who were here last term on the
combined education committee uh remember
that there were many examples of these
types of materials handed out in our
committee with members refusing to look
at them even though that they were in
our
schools and on the house floor members
reluctant to
hear from these materials that are in
their
schools um
so I I think that parents need a
mechanism and this in legislation is in
in intended to provide uh a minimum uh
process for a resolution of Parental
complaints thank you thank you are there
any questions or was I have
NATO thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question and bringing this
forward to us so I had a question on
page
two
uh line 36 uh
throughout
the the school principal or his or her
design shall determine whether the
material is the subject of the complaint
is harmful to miners do you think it
should be more uh brought to like the
school board and not just have one
person uh uh making that decision that
would be part of the complaint process
if you know start out with the principal
and um when necessary um go up uh um to
higher levels up uh through the State
Board of
Education but I I think it's uh
reasonable to start out at school level
thank
you any other questions representative
Hall thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question uh is this we
only Public Schools or public charter
schools or private schools religious
Schools they're all
schools it it's uh public schools and
and charter schools public schools um
yeah um I'm not touching um with this
schools follow up follow I'm just
wondering about the charter schools I
thought attorney Clinton had said that
it needed to say start of school do it
it um yeah I'm not I'm not sure
um if this does say Public public Char
of schools or not to be honest okay
thank
you representative Murray thank you
madam chair thanks for taking my
question I I did have a question I
believe I thought I heard you say that
you are referencing on page two one um
line 20 under the complaint process you
would uh said
that um I'm not sure if I did say that I
might have said that but I was looking
at a marked up version okay
um uh of the bill rather
the one that you're looking at I see and
follow up follow thank you um additional
question do districts already have um
challenge uh policies in place if they
find objectionable material if a parent
feels like there's a material that is
objectionable are you aware any
districts who already have the I I
believe there are districts that have a
process I just want to make um uh
setting a floor if you will in terms of
that process and make sure that parents
um are aware of their rights to appeal
to the State Board as
well any other
questions repesent Cornell Thank you
madam chair thank you for taking my
question isn't it already against the
law to give these kind of materials or
make available to miners these kinds of
materials
um I'm not sure where it is um against
the uh statutes in New Hampshire but I
think that um what we need to do is um
lay out a minimum complaint process but
also uh set an enforcement mechanism
when required and I don't believe that
that's anywhere in
statute follow well another question
thank you for taking my question um so
it said that there would be um damages
of $1,000 for each violation and cost
and reasonable legal fees who would pay
that would that be the Local District or
the taxpayers who would have to pay for
that if that was found U well U the
school
district but the school district is the
taxpayers correct y thank
you represent Murray thank you madam
chair I an additional question on page I
think this is one yeah um with regard to
uh line 19 subsection and that defines
nudity here um nothing talks about sort
of science or um the process for which
like you know um conversations with
communities who may not wear clothes or
science
or biolog human biology so I'm curious
to know um you're you're simply defining
nudity in
a non like a non-educational context but
I I'm just unsure of like in a human
biology class if there were
conversations
about right would that violate this uh
no no um I I I think that um you know
these are all taken from um uh US
Federal uh Court decisions um all these
definitions um and
um I think one one of the cases might be
gburg versus New York
um um but uh yeah this is not uh in
um materials that are harmful to minors
as uh um indicated elsewhere in the
statute in excuse me not statute but in
the legislation um I think that's on
page two uh page three excuse me no page
wrong representative
Hall thank you madam chair just a uh and
thank if you take my question just a
followup to representative Murray's
question like art classes you know
statue of David I mean you can't do that
anymore uh no that is not the intent of
this I don't think that those um things
like that would be uh indicated as uh
harmful to minors per the uh legislation
or and per um Court
decisions representative dry thank you
thank you for taking my
question reading a little further uh
it seems to me that something to in
order to be declared harmful has to meet
all four of the um per the
uh the elements one two three and four
on page two to be uh that includes
nudity in one of them but not all four
of them um to be declared obscene or
harmful that is correct thank
you representative Hall thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question um my question is
about um well this is about
minors and in our schools we have
students who are not
minors um so what happens to their
access to materials does it is it in the
library but only if you're not a minor
um I I think that
um uh I I assume that you're talking
about at the high school level probably
um and and um if that uh 18yearold or
19yearold
um they would not be a minor so they
would not be covered under this um so
they would have access to
materials um but um someone else who was
16 or 17 years old could um uh complain
about this or have their parents
complain about this uh material so if if
um The
Librarian um let's say there was a
complaint um by a 16-year-old's parents
and the uh material was found to be uh
inappropriate for that age group um then
they should be uh I would imagine that U
it would be possible that the library
would move that to a separate section um
that would be available to um someone
okay
represent representative
Bon thank you madam chair and thank you
um on page three uh line
21 uh that's section seven there um it
talks about the appealing to the State
Board of
Education um it says that an agrie
parent of a grief parent I think it's
supposed to be a grief parent or
Guardian may include a parent or
Guardian who is not the original
complaintant but one who is the parent
or guardian of a student for whom access
to material is determined uh to be
removed or restricted my question is as
an example if somebody takes it all the
way up to the State Board of Education a
particular book State Board of Education
says this book is not appropriate for
this age level does that mean that every
school district has to um abide by that
decision um I would think certainly that
that school district would and I would
hope that um the uh state board or the
department would um make uh make it
known that um that
material um was not appropriate for a
certain age level to uh other schools as
well
please um so if I'm understanding that
correctly um somebody could say I took
this appeal to the State Board of
Education in my town Ry and they said it
wasn't appropriate for the age level
somebody could take that information and
then say okay I'm going over to Hampton
and it's they've determined it it's not
appropriate the State Board hasn't
determined it's not appropriate for Ry
they can do the same thing and so it
would just kind of bounce around so that
one book um that was challenged wouldn't
be available Statewide I I think there
would have to be um communities are
different all right so I don't I think
that the appeal process would go through
um in that uh Hampton for instance that
well any other
okay
yeah I'm going to put a three minute um
time limit on for the rest of the
good afternoon thank you thanks for
hearing from me again um a couple of
things I wanted to bring up along with
this
um I am in
judiciary and um we have a bill that has
made it through J
Judiciary and I think most parents and
most people are not aware that if your
child minor takes a book out of the
library either at the
school or at the public library you have
a parent have no right to know what book
they have taken
out you don't have a right to know now
if you get a notice that the book is
overdue and you owe money and you call
the school or the public
library and ask well what book is
overdue they cannot take take tell you
and I don't think people are aware of
that but we have a bill that made it
through Judiciary that will change
that that's one thing the other thing
that came up that was very
heart-wrenching in judiciary is we have
a bill there that talks about children's
access to um a parents being able to put
um filters on their children's phones
and their eye and their iPhones and
their iPads and those filters are there
but parents have to access them well we
have a bill that says those those
filters will come on the phone for
Miners and parents will have to op out
and the reason why that came was because
of parents of children it's hard to
access to put those filters on to make
it better for the parents and better for
the children so that being said I think
this is Comm sense um I cannot take a
10-year-old to an X or an R-rated movie
I cannot take a 10-year-old into a store
to buy a
Playboy when I watch TV in the evening
it has things on it that say you know
under 14 that type of thing there are
video games that a 10-year-old cannot
access and cannot buy
to have the things in the school that
are being that are in the schools that
children have access to and as we know
from last year everyone was horrified
when representative uh cordelli started
to talk about them every stop stop you
you can't say those things but yet those
things were available to Children these
are our children one of the stories that
we heard in judiciary over about a young
boy who was accessing oh sorry thank
you please vote for this protect the
thank you uh Madame Vice chair
um um my name is jel bassinet I'm the
legal director of the ACLU of New
Hampshire and we're here in opposition
to this legislation and I just want to
make a few brief points because I know I
have three minutes and and certainly
want to be respectful of the committee's
time and the opportunity for those
behind me to um uh speak on this bill uh
the first point I want to make and it
was referenced uh with respect to one of
the questions is about what is the
connection between this legislation and
existing law and I did want to flag for
this committee that New Hampshire law
already prevents giving miners quote
harm from materials and I put that in
quote because we have a separate statute
um
571b that defines harmful materials and
wholesale prohibits those dissemination
that dissemination to minors both in the
school and and outside of the school
context and there's definitions baked
within that statute that are designed to
um codify and be consistent with the
Constitutional protections that we have
and the Constitutional standards that
courts have articulated including the
Ginsburg case that the sponsor
articulated before so I just want to be
be very clear about that and want to
encourage the committee to review um
that that statute because I do think in
light of that
statute um this bill certainly in my
brain kind of just presents some
questions which is you know is the
intent or does its
scope um go or is it intended to go
beyond what exists and existing law and
that actually would be concerning
because right the the existing law the
harmful material statute creates and
embodies constitutional standards and if
we're trying to restrict materials
beyond what exists in existing law and
Beyond what exists in those
constitutional standards there could be
serious constitutional concerns so I
just wanted to flag that um for the
committee um I do think again begs the
question do we need this if we have
existing law um and I I certainly think
it's a legitimate question with respect
to
um what if anything is this intended to
do beyond the existing law so I'll leave
it at that um but I do want to convey
some of the Constitutional or some of
the standards that are in this law and
how they may not be fully consistent
with constitutional principles um first
I just want to talk um a little bit
about um the definitions in it including
its expansiveness in so far as it
encompasses nudity and sexual excitement
um I'm not entirely sure what ex sexual
excitement means but in any event that
exceeds uh sexual conduct sexual conduct
is the obscenity standard that is used
um throughout the case law um it is the
standard that's used in existing law in
New Hampshire in the harmful material
statute so I just wanted to point out to
the committee that this does go beyond
that standard and that's just one of a
couple examples of I think one of the
the problems definitionally uh with this
law lastly I would want to talk about
the State Board of Education piece
because I do think that's meaningful
typically when we think about obscenity
we think about local standards state
board is a state standard they're not
elected and section one with respect to
obscenity I also think is um is
problematic and what apply to private
schools thank you I'm sorry for
exceeding my
time will take I had to rush of course
absolutely representative drive thank
you and thank you for taking my question
you still have time to get to your sure
okay um I understand that is already
harmful um a crime to show this material
to um minor but what we're talking about
is um the immunity that educational
institutions have from that law and I
think that K to 12 made up of minors for
the most part
99% applies here so why do you have a
problem with um with this with this bill
going and taking away that immunity well
I'm not entirely sure that's um that's
true with respect to 571b but I think
the point that I would make is that if
you're going to have a standard that
applies in the k312 context it needs to
be fully consistent right with the
obscenity standard and so one example as
I noted before this isn't limited to
sexual conduct it in fact goes beyond
that this is not fully consistent with
the local um local community St
Community standards because there is a
state board of education component to it
I don't know what the standard of review
is for the State Board of Education are
they looking at State stand standards
local standards typically when we think
about obscenity we think about local
standards because Community standards
evolve and change that to me is not
particularly clear in this legislation
especially given the fact that there're
a state border view I would encourage
this committee to remove that because I
think that is that is
problematic representative wuk thank you
m chair good afternoon thank you Fork
repres I'd like to go back to 571b
because I AB I know absolutely nothing
about it that um statute would that
Encompass as
well um private schools parochial
schools any any school um including
public or is that and I U because you're
talking about the New Hampshire statute
yeah and this bill deals with
specifically with K12 Public Schools it
exempts parochial exempts charter
exempts any of the schools so I'm trying
to find out if 571 is there a conflict
there or is cross over there I may I
think that's a great question I do want
to check on that to confirm the
applicability of 571b to K through2 and
higher education schools because I do
understand one of the intent behind this
is to change the criminal obscenity law
to kind of exclude k through2 um and it
it does so not by amending 571b but by
amending 654 the point why I want to
make there with respect to that change
in section one is that that that would I
think include K through2 private schools
too right because all you're doing there
is calling out higher education um but
with respect to whether 571b has an
exemption for schools currently I want
to just I want to check and I can get
back to the committee on that I don't
want to misstate anything with respect
to its application thank you thank you m
chair any other
questions representative
kuger thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question thank you um I
just wanted to clarify with you where it
says second on page two that school
districts would are required to have 14
days of notice for curriculum course
material so I'm making an assumption
here that this would not include
textbooks that are used for example for
health class related
purposes am I reading that
correctly it it depends on whether
someone use the contents of those
materials as feeding as satisfying the
definitions so that might be the intent
and if that is the intent to exclude
that I would certainly be clear um clear
legislation followup sure um because it
also mentions here that school boards
are required to require that their
schools provide developmentally
appropriate collection of instructional
resources so I'm assuming that that
protects textbooks in that
sense I I hope so I think the I think
that's the question right is you know do
these four elements the standards
articulated in this bill provide
protections for that material or is the
wording here problematic to the extent
that it could be argued that it's not
covered and that's why Clarity here is
so clear and why making sure that these
standards modify to the letter the
Constitutional standards is so important
so for example you know nudity should
that should not be the standard it
should be like consistent with current
law right it should be sexual conduct
that's one way to try to make this clear
to prevent that type of interpretation
and so we're more consistent with the
Constitutional standards that exist
thank
you representative Murray thank you um
Madam chair and thank you for taking my
question so with regard to higher ed
institutions um do we see that there are
potential some issues around the
constitutionality of uh challenging
materials at an institution of higher
ed I so now I think you're referring to
part one which kind of is
um I think that's I think that's a good
question I do think it seems like what
part one is designed to do is is
maintain the protections that exist
under the criminal obscenity statute for
highed so I want to just kind of
recognize that that I think is what the
intent is and and I think the purpose is
to limit that current exemption under
criminal obscenity law to the K through2
context I do think right when you when
you start engaging in um restrictions
certainly above the K through2 context
but I don't think is the intent here um
certainly the Constitutional standards
change right and and the standards you
know change um so I'll just leave it at
that thank you any other questions
seeing none thank you thank you madam
chair and thank you for the
accommodation I really appreciate it
you're welcome
representative
coren good afternoon my name is Lori
coren I am State Rep from Coos district
7 um I just wanted to talk about a
couple things
um when we when we send our kids to K
through 12 to the public school those
kids don't have a choice most of the
time um so we need to out of our way to
make sure that families are are okay
with that
um my I've done Foster and adoptive care
for 20 years well 15 in mass and then
some here um books that this bill wishes
to
address have really triggering effects
on some of the kids and Foster and
adoptive care um the last I checked
three in one females were sexually
abused in New Hampshire I think it was
five no three out of five uh one out of
five boys are sexually
abused when a parent sends their kids to
to public school they want to know that
when their kids are are in a public
library they're safe they're not looking
at things that are going to be
triggering um this happened to one of my
sons
um we need to be careful of what we're
putting in our Public Schools our
numbers are
dropping we need to reach out and make
sure these parents know that public
to I
just we need legislation like
this thank you any
sorry these are from books which are in
our libraries I thought they were just
in our middle schools when I passed
these out last year one of the Reps said
oh this is in our elementary school so
you might read this as even less than 10
years old
um we're not talking about whether or
not these are good books or not good
books in fact the first one on here
flamer is actually a pretty good book
for high school boys it would be a
terrible Book for a 10-year-old we don't
need our 10-year-olds wondering
if when they go to boy scout camp in the
summer if they're going to have to uh
come in a bottle or if they should be
considering suicide which are topics in
that book and it's a well-written book
it says it's a graphic novel it says the
reading level is two second grade but it
says the attend intended audience is 9th
through 12th grade not 9th through 12
years old
9th through 12th grade and yet it is in
at least one of our elementary schools
and many of our middle schools the
bottom one gender queer which does have
sexual activity in it for the definition
one of the previous speakers mentioned
it's written for
adults not
10-year-olds and the problem is these
images you can't get them out of your
head once you've seen them and I'm sorry
I passed them around for you to see them
but I want you to see and understand
these are not the worst images out there
these are just ones I was willing to
print they get worse
um this is I'm trying to think of
arguments people have had in the past
this is not an
anti-homosexuality bill I have numerous
homosexual friends good friends and they
have written many times um gays against
groomers and leav our children be
innocent for as long as possible and
they very much object to this material
being in our schools and our young
children seeing this
material and you may say well parents
can just you know go in and look well no
some school districts yes some school
districts no and I know of one we had
testimony of a dad who looked at the
quote unquote card Catalog online and
was relieved to find that his school
didn't have any of these books books and
then he went in to pick up his kid
partway through school for a doctor's
appointment or something and uh pop by
the library on the way no they weren't
online listed they were on full display
as you enter the library as recommended
reading that Dad took his kid out and
never brought him back and this is
mild sorry I could tell you what it was
compared to and I could tell you what
state law for libraries is
thank you any
questions seeing none thank you oh
represent withfield
thank you and thank you for taking my
question what what is the state law for
the public libraries well it it's
Federal actually and then it comes down
to the State library and it talks about
not just sexual
acts it um it includes a vast variety of
things including books which are spefic
specifically to arouse Etc I mean it's
it's along and I know that rep cordelli
has a copy of it I did not bring that
today but I can send it if you need um
and according to it none of these books
would be allowed and the instructions
are if the State Library gives funding
to any Library which has this type of
material then I mean if they give
funding and then that library is found
to have this type of material they have
to cut off funding for a few years so I
don't know if our State Library gives
any funding to our school libraries but
if they did they would be in
trouble thank you any other
questions per of
NATO thank you madam chair
um the gentleman from the ACLU stated
RSA 571 DB and it does
kind of
specifically State some restrictions do
you firmly believe that the the law
before us the bill before us will expand
on that and protect the children in the
libraries I think
um if I recall this bill was written
partly towards the laws for libraries
specifically which is federal which goes
beyond the um
RSA that was stated there and and we
follow those
federal guidelines laws thank you and
thank you for coming before
us any other
questions seeing none oh one more
represent Cornell I just I wanted to
clarify I'm sorry that the State Library
does not give any money to the school
libraries that's cool I'm glad um
and I personally have happen to think
that the school libraries would should
follow the same rules the State library
has to but thank
Benson good afternoon I have some
written testimony that I will hand out
uh Jacqueline Benson I am an author and
a regional leader for authors against
book bands we are Coalition of writers
illustrators and editors that oppose
unconstitutional efforts to limit the
freedom to read and I'm here today to
share some concerns about HB 324 as it's
currently written um I'd like to point
out that there is no existing definitive
list of which book books that have been
published in the United States meet the
legal definition of obscenity so
determining whether a challenged book is
puant or patently offensive or lacking
in literary value to use some of the
language from HB 324 is always going to
come down to a judgment call and if we
look at how those judgment calls are
being made around the United States
right now you can see that among the
most banned authors in last year's
record-breaking 10,000 plus School
library book bands were Margaret Atwood
Tony Morrison Ked heni Stephen King and
I think it's difficult to argue that
titles like The Bluest Eye or the
handmaid's tale which are among the most
influential books published in the 20th
century are pornographic and lack
literary merit so why are they being
banned because too often the Judgment
call about a book's appropriateness or
Merit is being made by a single
individual or body in a process that
excludes other voices a more robust and
reasonable uh policy would see Parental
challenges reviewed by an informed group
of
stakeholders that should include School
administrators but also Librarians
school media Specialists teachers school
board members and other parents from the
community who are also impacted by these
book
removals uh and in fact a stakeholder
based approach is probably a legal
necessity right now six major book
publishers and several best-selling
authors are suing the state of Florida
over a law very similar to this one as a
violation of constitutional Free Speech
rights and that suit was recently
greenlighted by a Flor Florida federal
court judge who called the state's
approach
capricious uh so in conclusion policies
related to the removal of material from
school libraries need to balance the
legitimate concerns of individual
parents against the constitutional
rights of other students and parents in
the community and I would therefore urge
the committee if they are looking at
establishing a precedent for this sort
of policy to make sure that it is a
thoughtful and inclusive one that brings
all the key stakeholders including
Librarians themselves were the ones
trained to assess the value of this
material to the table any
questions thank you representative dry
thank you and thank you for taking my
question I've always determined that
band book was one that no one could get
a hold of is that what applies to these
that you're calling band books I don't
think there's necessarily one single
definition for band book as the authors
against book bands looks at it if a book
is removed from a library and it is no
longer available to students to read
there we would call that band for those
students they would no longer have
access to that
book says 2025 there's lots of ways to
get access to books side your local
library there are if you can afford them
if you have access if you have
transportation if you have a budget part
of the foundation of our libraries in
this country was to ensure that access
to information was free and available to
communities representative Lichfield
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question sure um throwing this
at you probably not fair but because
you're an author um we had someone else
that had testified how there are ratings
on video games there are ratings on
movies even when you go to let's say a g
movie they might kind of pair down the
um the highlights or previews of other
movies to be more age appropriate why
don't they do this for
books it's a good question I don't have
an answer for that I know as an author
myself I voluntarily put a Content
warning at the front of my own books
that details any content people might
find challenging or triggering or
objectionable in the books so they can
make a conscious decision about reading
it but there isn't an industry standard
or a law that requires that kind of
rating process um I can't answer for you
why they haven't done that thank you
okay any other
thank you the committee and the the
chairwoman for hearing me speak today
it's my first time testifying so please
excuse any uh ums or nervous hands um my
name is Katherine gatam I am a resident
of Gerome I have a master's degree in
library and information science and I am
also a parent um I would urge this
committee to vote in expedient to
legislate on this bill as we have heard
and seen this bill is being introduced
as a way to protect children but what we
have seen in other states with similar
legislation is that this bill is
censoring materials for children who may
need the most uh pen America is
organization who tracks uh book
challenges across the country it was
just mentioned there were over 10,000
last year this was a uh 200% increase in
those challenges only 133% of them
showed sex on the page uh this could be
uh a book written for teenagers it could
be uh a sex education book uh but the
majority of these titles are not uh that
are that are objected to are not
actually showing sex on the page so I
think that's important uh to keep in
mind when we say obene you know what
does that what does that really mean and
what it often becomes is books that are
targeting lgbtqia plus characters and it
is so important for children to see
themselves in the books that they read
books should be a mirror to your own
experience you know children and teens
they're still learning about themselves
their identity it is validating to see
themselves in the books they read and
books also can be a window into the
world around you uh so children and
teens they are learning empathy they are
learning about the world around them and
we need to give them uh the resources to
do so um as a librarian you know I've
talked to families children teens given
them those resources and I think for
many kids the school library is a
lifeline and and books can really save
their lives um as a librarian we follow
collection development policies we read
professional reviews and we are trying
to ensure that our collections are both
age appropriate and relevant to the
communities that we serve um it is
absurd to think that any librarian at
least any librarian I know or have had
the pleasure of working with is out to
harm children with the materials that we
are providing to them in schools um I
think as a parent certainly we have the
right to guide our children in what they
are reading and consuming but it is not
right for one parent to dictate what an
entire school district is able to access
um so with that being said I I urge you
all to vote in expedient to legislate on
this Bill thank
you thank you representative dve thank
you uh thank you for taking my question
I'm GNA ask the same question here you
say it's AES represents a clear
attempted book Banning and do you
consider Banning just that some people
can't do it or just that no one could
get it yeah I think I would Echo the
sentiments that were just shared that
when we use the book term book ban and
maybe this is a divisive term that that
should be considered to say something
else it's a it's attempted censorship we
are Banning a child in that school
access to that book that child can no
longer access that book in the school so
in that sense I would say yes this is a
a book ban thank
you thank you and thank you for taking
my question so earli in your testimony
you testified about uh certain children
needing to be able to see certain
material I'm looking at a picture from a
book gender queer where there's a male
providing oral sex on another male and
I'm just wondering who who in their
right mind would need to see something
like this at an age such as 10 years old
um to that specific book I would say
that book is an adult title um and I
think that as I mentioned as Librarians
we have collection development policies
that clearly State uh you know we look
at professional reviews that book has
been reviewed for adults it has won
awards um and so yeah this is a a
renowned title um for adults and I think
to answer your question should a
10-year-old read that book that book is
not written for 10-year-olds um so I I
think that's how I would respond to your
question thank
you followup so I take your answer to
that is 10-year-old should not be seeing
that
material I am saying that Librarians
follow collection development policy
gender queer is a book written for
adults and it it is as a librarian in my
library um I did not have that book in
my teen section of the public library
that is in the adult
section I clarifies thank you
L Lichfield thank you madam chair and
thank you for taking my
question
so if I heard you correctly you
mentioned that 133% of the 10,000 books
were found sexually explicit do you
realize that that IS300 books that's and
my question is what is the organization
I'm sorry I missed it yeah the
organization is pen America could you
spell just pan it's pen pen America and
again that also included books uh about
sexed um stories I mean teenagers need
to see their experiences on the page um
teenagers are may be sexually active and
this could this is a safe way for them
to understand their bodies um again I
think it's all about that that
professional discretion of the librarian
this book is written for teens I'm not
suggesting that we put this in the hands
of a first
grader
just thank you and thank you for taking
my question M but are you putting the
opinion of the librarian over the
opinion of the parent oh certainly not
as a parent as I said I believe that
parents have the right to to decide what
a child is is reading um if I don't want
my child reading that book then I will
not allow them to to read the book but
it's
available yeah
Rel one more question I'm sorry thank
you but I we heard earlier today that
actually I was a co-sponsor on that bill
that the parents do not have access to
what the children are taking out of the
library so how would the parent know I
think it's about communication I cannot
speak for every parent in their
relationship that they have with their
child um and I think I what I will say
is that we need to rely on the
professionals to to look at these
resources and review them um and not one
parent should be able to take a book
away from an entire group of
people representative Bon thank you
madam shair and thank you for taking my
question it goes along with what you've
been talking about as a school librarian
if a parent had um reason to be
concerned about what their child was
reading and sent him a note and
requesting would you adhere to the their
wishes in terms of what their CH child
could take out of the library yeah thank
you for your question um was not a
school librarian I was in a public
library so I can't speak to what I what
a school librarian may or may not do but
I um I think
that again it's about that relationship
with with your child and and respecting
you know building that relationship and
having an understanding of what they
they are or not
reading
yeah representa Morse thank you thank
you for taking my question again uh
based off your testimony when it comes
to parental oversight with these books
and in their children's hands currently
there may not be any parental oversight
with the current way that schools are
run and their libraries are run so it
almost sounds to me like you'd be in
favor of this bill because it would
allow parental oversight whereas
currently there is none am I wrong no
that is incorrect and I apologize if I
have miscommunicated my uh sentiments on
this topic um what I am saying is that
as a
parent I can tell my daughter she's two
so we're reading we're reading muala a
laot right now okay but I can I can
choose what my daughter is reading and
as she gets older we can have
conversations but I do not feel it is
right for one parent to dictate what an
entire School Board of entire school
accessing follow follow
up so particular with the book I
mentioned a little while ago would you
allow your 10-year-old to be able to
read a book as such respectfully I don't
think that is relevant to this thank
you any other
questions seeing that thank you thank
sure Pasha Roberts or
remember okay well good morning um
honorable members of the education
committee and I am posha Roberts I live
in wilmet New Hampshire and I'm the on
the board of 63 equality and I'm
speaking today against HP
324 so proponents of this bill will be
and actually already are parading
cherry-picked extreme sounding material
before this committee today please do
not mistake the forest for the
trees first any child with a phone or
internet connection can easily find any
of this
and more without having to go through
the trouble of reading a book the reason
that these books are deemed dangerous is
not their spicy scenes but the narrative
power of the stories inside of them
these controversial books including
gender queer are not stories about the
pizza man coming to the house these are
coming of age stories with emotional
Nuance they're companions for young
adults as they navigate the difficult
corridors of growing up in 2020 5 the
books frankly walk through the life and
challenges of real raw people by reading
about them a reader can decide whether
they are or are not like these
characters I trust them to do that kids
are
smart there is a moral
Panic around gender in this country
young adults who question whether they
are gay lesbian or transgender are
particularly at risk of having every
shred of affirming narrative removed
from their Library
I don't want them growing up in a desert
as I did in particular as a sexual abuse
Survivor I would have benefited
tremendously by seeing material that
described what I went through even with
the pictures that you don't like that
normalized it took me out of isolation
and gave me some insight about what I
might do about it what I might do next
how I might
survive some of these books deemed
obscene will be Lifesavers for abused
kids and at their healing Society will
be better for it that is their literary
value in other states versions of this
law have been used by small groups of
individuals to prosecute a very narrow
religious view onto Public Schools a
single Agri parent could use the vague
aggressive peran bounty hunting passages
of HP 324 to cost the school district
thousands of dollars ruining the careers
of well-meaning school personnel it will
lead to a chilling effect over
compliance out of fear and empty shelves
this is not Freedom this is not Live
Free or Die Here No Good has ever come
from centering books it might sound odd
but kids need these books I emphatically
encourage you to vote this bill
itl any questions representative drive
thank you and thank you for ask
answering this question we had someone
testify a few minutes ago about tra kids
who have had um uh tra uh traumatic
experiences and this being a trigger for
them instead so I wonder how you balance
those things sure thank you for the
question I am a survivor I can tell you
that if I saw something that I wouldn't
have been I wouldn't find the book I'd
be looking for a book that said that
tells me what did somebody else go
through I mean these books didn't start
coming out until like the 80s it was a
desert um and these books start coming
out it it feeds you you may and I'm I'm
glad you don't understand it means you
haven't had to go through this so
congratulations but if you've been
through that kind of dark experience it
really makes a huge difference to
actually see it normalize it understand
and know that you're not alone because
that's what the abusers do they make you
alone thank
you representative mors thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question
similar to what um representative dry
said as a sexual abuse Survivor first
off I just want to apologize for you
having to go through that I myself had
the same situation happened a few
different times in my history um and it
does suck now um I was wondering how in
situations like you've mentioned where
books could have been beneficial for you
in recovery in essence yeah um is there
a specific book or instance that you had
that helped you recover because for me
it had the opposite effect
not I mean the first book that really um
um you might not be able to tell but I'm
a little old so these things books
didn't exist I mean the first book that
really I came into was the courage to
heal which came out in
1988 um which is um you know well after
I came out of school if I had found that
wow um you know and there's still a very
few books for male survivors so having
um material on that in particular would
have been amazing
any other
questions see you none thank you okay
thank
West hello members of the committee my
name is McKenzie West and I am here to
speak against House Bill 324
under the rather confusing language of
this bill it amounts to a book ban that
financially incentivizes parents to
attack Public public education and
school resources that are already
stretched then under this bill parents
will have the ability to challenge book
selections available in public schools
to further prudish and religious Intrust
against the will of the
majority this bill aims to be a solution
to a problem that does not verifiably
exist on Mass since when does a school
library carry books that are
inappropriate for the Target
demographic the truth of the matter is
they do not and that is already
accomplished through the underpaid and
underappreciated work of school
librarians and
administrators what this bill aims to do
is in part Target queer people to say
that our existence is inherently and
falsely sexual and therefore deemed
inappropriate for school
children as a trans woman and a lesan is
my experience inherently
inappropriate many proponents of this
bill and the ones like it would argue
yes even though my experience is no more
explicit or inappropriate than any CIS
hat experience those
prominent seek to erase similar sto
stories to mine so that they can erase
people like me it signals an early stage
of genocide and in the end it protects
no one what are are the kids to learn
when we blind them to in ignorance and
darkness and how do we prepare them for
the world when we only tell them
sanitize stories that don't cover the
experiences of a varied
population I hope that we don't let
ignorance and darkness win and I urge
you to vote itl and house bu
324 thank you any
questions seeing none thank you very
much
AJ
klei hello I think I wrote two minutes
on the thing but if you're giving people
more I'll take it um so I actually wrote
this in preparation I guess seems to me
that the government's motive behind
attempting to address these kinds of
impressionistic issues into neatly laid
out objective regulations is very
plainly an ongoing effort to create a
common enemy among a group of people who
they pretend to sympathize with the
average everyday Americans or the silent
majority but really we working class
families haven't a single reason not to
unite as human beings I think we all
want to protect our children as seen in
the current constitutional Protections
in place prohibiting obscene material
for miners so in such a time of genuine
Countrywide turmoil the attention being
given to these kinds of bills all across
the nation translates to me like
needless pot stirring we all think
showing kids inappropriate contents no
good but we literally can't even afford
groceries right now why during a
legitimate crisis are we choosing to
fight culture wars instead of getting
all hands on deck to improve our most
dire struggles for things like housing
and food not only are we being fooled
into becoming more divided with this
crap but and distracted from our biggest
problems but I feel like it's pretty
dumb for politicians to try and codify a
paradigm into law and this goes for any
sort of Paradigm doesn't matter if it's
bigoted or not it just doesn't work to
address OT Ally charged right brain
issues with a strong armed left brain
regime that only sees everything in
Black and White legal definitions
function the most properly when they
concern unquestionable facts and are
straightforward such as murder a person
often clearly appears either dead or
alive um you know what kind of stuff I
think is less clear of an ultimate legal
definition words like inappropriate in
artistic and shameful like that's that's
in the bill or whatever I mean just take
the sentence in the bill it goes the
material
if the material lacks serious literary
scientific medical artistic or political
value for minors then it can be
considered harmful each person defines
something's value differently especially
artistic or political value not to
mention the way serious is thrown in
there how is one to Define on an
objective basis the meaning of serious
value the whole thing just reeks of
personal bias if I were you I would be
very questionable of all this um all
right and then when the person was
introducing this build they were using
words like pornographic graphic to
describe I think they said like some kid
was reading a pornographic book and they
asked for a graphic copy or the library
asked if they want a graphic copy be a
little bit more specific with your
language I don't understand this
ambiguity and the vagueness um again
when representative sorry no I can't do
that
um I learned I can't do that um earlier
in your testimony you mentioned a
certain group of people who need to
certain see a certain kind of material
again why we not being specific here it
feels like we're purposefully hiding
behind this like professional formal in
the name of Public Safety sounding
rhetoric when in reality we're doing
unconstitutional things that are not
okay just me but I I don't know um also
what X or R rated movies are being shown
in schools what schools have Playboy
magazines in their libraries come on
people um why do you think numbers are
dropping in the public Ed system it's
terribly funded and it's the government
fault that sucks not teachers I could
keep going all right I'm done though
right that was the timer that was three
all right I think I'm I think I made a
point right oh wait do you guys have
questions does anybody have any
questions represented
Woodcock gosh I wish I heard the whole
thing um I didn't catch where you were
from I'm from gwn okay thank yeah yeah
of course I do cool all right thanks
thanks guys I've been here a lot this
[Laughter]
hi my name is Betsy Harrington I'm from
daring I have two kids who attend
Hillsboro deing High School I'm here to
represent the reality of what is being
presented to kids in public schools I
have worked as a sex offender counselor
at the state prison so I'm well aware of
what tools are used to groom and offend
our children four years ago my
freshman's son first showed me
inappropriate Library content that was
being promoted to his buddy through his
school Chromebook he was sent to the
principal for reading it out loud the
principal agreed it was inappropriate
but just sent him to his next class
nothing was ever done about the presence
of the inappropriate content so I
decided to look at his School's online
library app called sora for myself I was
absolutely shocked at what I saw it
wasn't just age inappropriate content
but i w it privately connecting our
children to sex-seeking adults through
their school Chromebooks let me explain
the school book the book titled this
book is gay by Juno Dawson is widely
available in the Sora student Library
shared New Hampshire online collection
the book has working hyperlinks to
match.com in the part of the book
entitled how sex apps work it then goes
on to explain what is wanted and
expected from who they meet up with it
tells them how to perform every possible
sex act including acts I as a sex
offender have never heard of it
blatantly gives sex misinformation
linking kids to sex-seeking adults
already has a name we call it sex
trafficking the problem of age
inappropriate content in our schools is
very real our kids are in actual danger
if we don't re in the Liberties that
some of these organizations are taking
with our kids some boundaries need to be
set here when when I first brought up
the issue with my school board privately
they banned my children from using all
School libraries as their solution that
was four years ago Banning top students
from using School libraries won't solve
this problem promoting age inappropriate
content to school children isn't right
no matter how you present it it's
undeniably inappropriate we need a
system that weeds out the legitimately
dangerous age inappropriate books in our
school libraries we wouldn't allow
penous stories to be an option yet the
book I've been describing is
exponentially worse than any Penthouse
story I'm aware of a disturbing incident
that occurred at kirar high school
during their recent deliberative session
taxpayers were put into the library as
an overflow space a parent randomly
picked up a book and opened it to a
picture of an actual orgy a scene of an
undressed man sitting in a chair with a
woman on her knees bent before him head
between her his legs with two other
women at his sides with his fingers in
their mouths she showed the book Saga
series book four to others in the crowd
including the police the book was
ultimately removed I think everyone can
agree pictures of orgies are
inappropriate for school libraries
taxpayers don't want to pay for over
sexualizing kids they'd rather protect
them please see the necessity of this
bill and vote to support it I'm happy to
answer any questions and I hope I get
the opportunity to show you I have the
Sora app right here on my phone ready to
show you exactly what I
mean thank you are there any questions
representative litfield thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question
could you please repeat to me the name
of the app Sora s o r a it's widely
available it's not available in every
public school but it's widely available
and there is a shared collection called
the New Hampshire shared collection and
this book with that sex trafficking link
is in it so it's literally widely
available to thousands of high school
students around our state and could be
other schools besides High School I know
the way it's um put in the Sora app that
it it should be just for high school
students if the librarian is doing their
job represent Paul chair I think we take
my question so that story was four years
ago this app right four years ago my
kids haven't used the library since then
so you don't know if that's still
happening you're it still there I have
the app so my kids aren't allowed to use
it so I have it on my phone here so I
can show you I have it open on my phone
right now this book is gay and I can
show you the hyperlink but my question
the question is followup question
followup okay thank you um is that
schools have filters I
mean you're sure right now the school
can access that link every kid in the
every kid in the state of New hav can
access that link or some kids I you have
proved that that's the case so any
school can add or subtract a book from
this from this app so they can make it
for their you know used best for their
own school it comes free it's
$250 to get over 8,000 books so that
book comes free with that New Hampshire
shared collection that everyone who gets
Sora gets that in New
available yet now the librarian would
have to remove that book because it
automatically comes free with that
Library one more follow please sure okay
the question is all students in the
state of New Hampshire if the school if
that whatever that app is they can click
on those links and get live action or
whatever you're talking about any
student that has the Sora app that it
that H their librarian could remove this
book so My Librarian has not it's
available to my kids but any child that
uses the Sora app could use that they
take the book out just like I have it
right here I can show you because it's
my kids account and they can link to
match.com in the part of the book that
says how sex apps work that's sex
trafficking I was a sex Defender
counselor I know what it
means we need
this any other
good afternoon for the record anry
Banfield I'm a parental rights Advocate
education researcher focused on acade
academic excellence and education I
think we're starting to hear why so many
families are leaving the public
schools so stopit now.org is a is an
organization that's directed towards
stopping sexual abuse in children and if
you go to that website there is a
portion that says when you hand children
pornographic or obscene materials it's
considered child sexual
abuse
so that's the part that I'm going to
talk about I get that there are
subjective books in the library and when
I get a call from a parent about
something like that my advice to them is
you know I I think that there's books
that we don't like going to have to get
over it and then there's where you cross
a line and we're seeing when you're
crossing a line and that's pornography
obscenity when you are crossing a line
when you can't listen in in the chambers
to what the representatives reading
we're crossing a line and they Define it
as child sexual
abuse I do think that there should be
transparency I don't think that this
bill probably goes far enough I do
support it but I would like to see more
transparency so parents can get more
involved because I think with when when
parents are more involved then see this
they're not quite as likely to run from
the school or pull their kids out of the
school that now they feel like at least
so you can opt out of objectional
materials in school and again I don't
want the objectional materials in the
same
category um but you know the Supreme
Court justice justice Potter Stewart was
asked to describe his test for obs in in
1964 and he said I know it when I see it
I think we all know it when we see
it picture of two males engaged in oral
sex and I don't care if it's two males
or a male and a female I mean making
this about the lgbtq community it
doesn't matter it could be heterosexual
there is a line and when you cross over
it that's where I think that this bill
is trying to go let's stop with where
you're crossing over that line or at
least let's have a parent be part of a
process to logically and and make an
argument as why this is harmful to
Children I've never seen a parent take a
Biology book to a school board and say
this is inappropriate when they're
trying to teach biology I don't know
about you but I haven't seen it um
you're also asking taxpayers to pay for
this and that's why you know I look for
things like how can we come together on
this how can we find a way to address
this issue that's driving some families
out of the public schools I mean you're
against efas or you're for efas and then
when you set these situations up that
drive parents out I'm like can we find
something that keeps them in the school
where they don't have to pull their kids
out because it's not
familyfriendly
um these books I'm sorry I think are
used to also groom children that's all I
have to say are there any questions
representative litfield thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question my question is um we had
another representative bring up
questioning if had it been several years
since there were issues with these books
I know as a child advocate you get calls
I'm ass I don't know how often you get
them what was the most recent call you
received or have you received from the
past six months or year is this is this
an older problem that's kind of
resolving itself or is this ongoing I
think what you're experiencing is people
giving up I think what you're
experiencing is is people saying I'm not
going to bother going to my school board
because they don't listen to me or my
schools and they don't listen to me so
they just pull their kids out and so
when you hear less and less and yes I do
hear from parents still yes I certainly
do um but what happens is after a while
people you have a you have a school
choice you can you can make that you can
now make that decision to pull your kids
out and go somewhere else you know we
have
ratings I think it was you that asked
about the ratings on movies and things
like that that's very parent friendly
you know I can look at at a movie you
know when my son was growing up uh he
had a a a friend that would come over
and his parents
said this the boy wasn't allowed to
watch or read Harry Potter Potter books
my son read Harry Potter books but he
didn't pull them out and give them to
his son it's called respect I respected
her we had a difference of opinion but
it's like we need to show some parents
respect that means making things
transparent so parents can be involved
and then they're not throw you know
having to remove their kids but yes it's
still going on it's still going on I
just think that things sometimes die
down I I see it in other areas you know
getting people to come out and and speak
before you they're I've given up I've
taken my kid out why why would I even
bother coming
here any other
Bennett hello Cindy Bennett from Raymond
and this is my first time uh speaking to
a committee so thank you for this is a
very big privilege that we have to share
and to um have free speech so um I
really appreciate this honor um I'm
coming here in favor of this bill um I'm
from Raymond I'm a mother of 13 I'm also
a teacher I have become a school board
member and a library trustee I am here
to support this bill and ask you to vote
in favor of it back when I was a kid
this bill wouldn't have been a thing
since it was agreed on by society that
pornographic images are harmful to
children and should be hidden from them
I can remember even brown paper on
magazines at the grocery stores fast
forward to when I don't know but I can
tell you I began to hear things in 2020
especially that were very disturbing and
about content leaking into schools that
is inappropriate I thought not in New
Hampshire New Hampshire's safe in July
2021 I went to a board meeting at the
Timberlane District on invitation of a
friend and my ears and eyes were shocked
this was July 15th 2021 at the
Performing Arts Center in plastow I have
some of this meeting recorded on my
phone I also have the minutes printed to
share the information I heard some of
the discussion was about mask wearing
and some of the information I did not
expect to hear there were parents there
that were upset that 22 children were
chosen by some teachers to form a club
with kids and kids were told not to tell
their parents the parents found out a
few weeks after the club started and
were enraged they came to this meeting
and read some of the content the kids
were exposed to police hating negativity
to First Responders and sexual content
materials I was not only shocked by what
the parents were saying but I was also
shocked by some of the board members
attitudes and reactions to the content
some of the board members were quite
disrespectful to the very parents who
had been deceived by these actions some
of the school board members actually
argued when asked to investigate this
matter further I have video of their
reactions I did not keep up with the
follow through on this day but it did
open my eyes to the possibility of the
problems we might have throughout New
Hampshire Public Schools the fact is
inappropriate content was presented to
children without the parents' knowledge
parents should never have to fear that
the school is doing anything to harm
children and especially behind their
back this can and is happening in New
Hampshire I also know from hearing
Rumblings around my town that parents
don't want to step up against these
types of things for fear that their kids
might be treated badly because of it of
course parents don't want their kids to
be treated badly because they they they
are trying to protect all of the
children I support this bill because it
brings back to the Forefront that
parents are to be respected as their
child's protection and nothing should be
happening in the school that will harm
children and anything of pornographic
nature will be dealt with in a strong
and intentional manner with the child's
safety at utmost importance my question
to you is isn't there enough information
for children to study without resorting
to sexual content that is not
appropriate for children kids are in
school to exercise their brains and to
learn how to learn to be educated and
Reading Writing and arithmetic stay in
that lane and the kids will be
fine thank you are there any
questions seeing none thank you
representative rats I wanted to answer a
good
afternoon I want to start by saying I'm
in support of HB 324 before I run out of
time Dear
honorable members of the New Hampshire
education
committee my name is Kevin gagan I'm a
widowed single parent of two children
attending the sau57 public school system
in Salem New
Hampshire in the fall of
2021 I discovered a story of a parent
verbalizing the words in details of an
obscene book readily available to minor
students
in front of her Local School Board in
another
state her description of the contents of
the book was so graphic and vulgar that
the board asked her to stop
speaking and was told there are children
at the
meeting seems that her point was made
education I immediately wondered could
have materials be here in Salem New
libraries getting to the answers to
these questions was not easy and
eyeopener I feel that these obscene
books are often made easily accessible
to minors but not
adults also to not judge a book by its
cover but by the content and lack of
moral
character the discovery of OB obscene
materials available to miners here in
Salem New
Hampshire uh led to the to finding
similar contradictions within the sau57
administration
policies policy
ehaa regarding Tech techology
responsible use
States obscenity is
illegal and not
tolerated obscenity generally includes
but is not limited to sexually explicit
or pornographic content a sexually
offensive word or combination of words
potentially I'm sorry profanity swearing
or an
expression or content in including lewd
images questions about obscenity should
be directed to the school
administrator consequences for violating
enforcement of this policy requires
Community Support student faculty or
staff that become aware of violation of
any portion of this policy must
immediately notify their building
administrator the building admo will
then notify the director of it violation
of any portion of this policy can result
in loss of access and may result in
additional disciplinary or legal
action boy that that's so fast just as
just as I fear all right guys bookl
booklook s.org put that in your notes
because I heard other people and just
give me a minute please because I've
been working on this for like three four
years I'm a parent all right and I do
this by myself and I'm really tired of
the inappropriate nature of what we are
battling to some of these wonderful
speakers before me uh pointed out that
this is absurd when I was a young a
young person at school I went into my
library I'm I'm just going to go off the
cuff here when I went into my library
the extent of this type of concern as a
parent was a National Geographic
Magazine with a woman breastfeeding her
child and yeah I might have Snicker or
whatever with my kids but the point is
it it's got changed quite a bit in 35 40
years okay uh there's a serious problem
and that's what I was going to get to
I've gone to the school board two three
times I removed my son from the school
to somebody's point here uh Miss amarie
Banfield she's absolutely right I pulled
my kid from the school and he he begged
me to take him back to the public school
for his Christmas wish all right that's
all he wanted for
Christmas and I work my butt off driving
him back and forth from Salem to Newton
New Hampshire for a nice charter school
that you know doesn't play games with
this type of stuff back to other
speakers point point when it comes to
education this is an education committee
can we not all agree math English
science reading history that's all the
kids need to know about and I'm sorry uh
you know when it comes to sex I'm
oldfashioned my late wife would have
called me a prude right but I believe
that that's something that any human
being insects animals Etc you don't need
an education on that right when we go
into the woods of New Hampshire you you
think the deer in in in the in the Moose
need an education on that no Kevin do
you have testimony that you could leave
with us I could send it in an email I
this in full disclosure I'm just
repeating what I said last time when
Glenn graciously introduced this bill
and and and actually I couldn't make it
here because I'm pretty busy at home and
I asked Val representative Valerie
McDonald from my town to read it for me
but because she was Green at her
position she was she went out of order
and was unable to complete my testimony
are you willing to take questions I
absolutely would love questions bring
them is there any
questions seeing none oh come on guys
thank you drove all the way from
Salem but you can email your testimony
in yeah let's bring sanity back to
education please thank
you yeah this
one it's kind of chocked up with n uh
sorry teres bastor Ash loud in New
Hampshire thank you for your time I know
it's been a long day for you guys so I'm
going to go quickly this was brought to
my attention a couple years ago and I
too have two children that I adopted
that have been sexually abused and we
are trying to teach them what is normal
and what is not normal we do not need to
normalize abuse that is not how you help
a
victim they need to know what happened
to them was not okay so that they don't
recycle those behaviors that being said
when this was first brought to my
attention I quickly said what is the New
Hampshire law on child pornography
children in sex acts and if you look at
649 a colon 3
it is anything that is to buy Pro
procure process of a child engaging in
sexually explicit conduct it is a class
a felony I brought that straight to
Frank edel and I said how is this not a
felony that we have a child who's giving
oral sex to an adult in our public
school if I'm caught with this material
it's a class a
felony and he said trce you're
absolutely right but there's some sort
of exemption for school
libraries when they're not accountable
to 649
a
649a colon 3 there's your language and I
said that has got to
change if any of us is caught with this
material it's a class a felony a child
giving an adult oral sex a child in an a
sex act by procure possess of a child
engaging in sexually explicit conduct
the language is very clear it is not
ambiguous why there would ever be an
exemption and this material to be
allowed in an elementary public school
when my husband and I between the
business and my job which I'll probably
be late
for are spending $40,000 a year in taxes
to the
state we want Reading Writing and
arithmetic you leave the parenting to
the
parents and how dare you even consider
something that would be a class a felony
to be allowed our hyperlinks to
match.com I ask each and every one of
you you have been elected to do a great
job at $100 a year I am so grateful for
your Civic your cic duty please do write
by my two boys I'm doing my best to
raise them up in the way they should go
and I need your help to make sure
they're safe when they go to their
public school thank you for your time
thank you are there any questions
seeing none thank
you is there anyone else who wishes to
speak on this
[Music]